Four,
three,
two.
Wow.
And we're live.
Today is uh,
Wednesday,
November first,
which means sober.
October is over.
I have saved my indulgence to be here
with you on Benjamin.
It's such an honor.
We're going to drink some,
uh,
William Wolff.
Bourbon.
It's perfect.
Not sure where I got this.
I believe somebody gave it to me.
I hope it's not poisoned.
Got Trust the wealth.
I have a little list that will spark up
a dube or it is the party started.
Cheers,
brother.
Grandson,
October man.
Thank you.
I had not sober October.
I bet you did.
I saw some tweets.
Benjamin likes to go off.
I appreciate that.
But you know what,
man,
that's a fucking.
That's a last thing.
The ability to go off crazy shit.
Everybody is so God damn scared of
repercussions of being protested.
I mean everybody's being hashtag called
out.
I now and it's just like,
it immobilizes people.
It's like,
that's why like a season to this season
of stranger things.
You're watching that.
I like it.
I like hopper,
like the cop because he'll get pissed
and be like,
sorry.
It's because I just care so damn much.
You could do that shit in the eighties.
Oh,
sweet taste of marijuana and marijuana
and 31 days.
All right.
Well that's nice.
How's it feel?
It feels good to be back.
It feels good.
I missed it.
I tell you what though.
I enjoyed being sober.
Not that I needed to be sober,
not like a junkie with the problem,
but it's nice to take a reset.
I'm going to do it every year.
I'm going to do sober October every
year.
They you heard is good.
So gear yourselves up,
ladies and gentlemen.
Eleven months from now.
Join on in.
Maybe.
Maybe all in won't.
What do you think?
Oh No,
I'm in man.
Let's do it.
I'll do sober October because this year
I uh,
I just hit my foot with an ax.
He such a.
you're so are living in the boonies men.
I don't know anybody in La that good.
Tell me that.
Where I wouldn't call the police and
say,
uh,
I don't know why the fuck he swinging an
ax but feet checked.
Well yeah,
because my brother does tree work so I
usually wear the good the boots,
you know,
but,
but I,
we,
we fire,
we have fires every uh,
every night and I really liked tinkering
to make the fire good.
And then I cracked some beers and then
my family hangs out and then they go
inside and a crack more beers and I de
chops more wood and uh,
I didn't put on the good boots and uh,
my ax just careened off off and hit me
in the foot.
So.
And I didn't,
uh,
I didn't have time to,
to get stitches,
so I just put a maxi pad on it and it
worked.
How big was the cut?
Is Pretty legit.
They say you should use,
um,
whenever possible.
If you can't get anywhere you can use
crazy.
I've
never tried that,
but I know a lot of people who have.
And I know fighters who've gotten cut in
camp and just use crazy glue krazy glued
up to the cut and then made it to the
fight.
That's awesome.
Didn't let anybody know that they had a
preexisting injury.
Those guys are hard as nails.
There's a lot of them that they'll go
into the octagon with some crazy shit.
What is this fleet?
What happened to him?
Flee plays doctor with superglue.
Oh,
most people cut themselves.
Bally had the emergency room,
but when red hot chili peppers basis
flea,
cut his thumb open,
aggressively strumming his guitar during
a show.
He didn't have time for surgery,
so keeping it crafty,
picked up bottle,
superglue,
seal that cut like any good shirtless
rockstar would.
Yeah,
I would do that in a heartbeat.
Like like cuts or wounds.
I'm all about just like doing shit like
that.
It's like broken bones.
Yeah.
That's when I.
I know I've got to set it or so.
Yeah,
that seems like a flea move.
He seems like a psycho.
It was just pulled it out of his sock
guy.
I remember they did an article once he
was talking about is how important is
pre-performance shits are,
and I was like,
yeah,
they are important,
but why is everybody?
Why are we ashamed of a bowel movements?
Why we shamed a potty?
I don't know.
Maybe we should be honored to get rid of
toxins.
Jamie and I were talking about it openly
because you got some new bathrooms for
the studio that have those Japanese
toilets at shoot hot water up your butt.
Oh yeah.
And they're warm.
So you sit in the toilet.
It's heated like right away.
It's like a warm,
comforting,
like come in,
come in and shit.
Come in and just release.
Relax those bowels and let it go.
Let it go.
That's awesome man.
I'm,
I'm real meat and potatoes with my
shifts.
I just,
I get in and get out,
but you know if there's another level to
it,
like what you're describing.
I want an.
Sometimes I'm disturbed though after it
shoots hot water up my ass for five
minutes and then I use toilet paper and
wipe it down and it's still.
I see poop.
I'm like,
well what the hell?
I haven't had any of those yet.
It's been all clean every time I'd be
louder than mine.
Is there like a lot of water?
Is it like you can move it around,
you can like five different conditions.
It can spread wider general,
or is it like,
oh,
it's just right.
It's just perfect.
It shoots all over the place.
You could get it to go all over the
place.
I forget.
Desires have more than one.
A can an aim to more than one spot.
Like with a button.
Yeah,
yeah,
you can move it,
but it's the fact yet.
Right.
But then there's also a friendship which
is obvious,
so women,
but for know where that fits.
Hammer your boss or you can do a ball
shot.
I saw some dude on TV.
It got hit no on the Internet.
Rather a video clip of someone who he
the guy in front of,
he was a catcher and the guy in front of
him just barely clipped the ball and it
Corinne to perfectly and it was nuts.
Can you see this fast ball?
As hard as Paul just targeted his nut
sack bang.
And even though it's a like an animated
gift,
it's only a couple seconds long and as
soon as that ball hits the ground,
you see his body just given like,
oh,
it was like precision.
Like I played lacrosse and that once.
Oh this is that it.
No.
Well I should have said I should have
retweeted.
That was being selfish with it.
You're being selfish with the ball hit.
No.
Sometimes I don't read tweak things even
though they're good and then I go,
why didn't I retweet that?
And then I killed,
try,
go back and find them and they just lost
the sea of replies at replies where they
just get,
I can't.
Here it is.
I think this is it.
Yeah,
that's it.
Watch this and that might have them go
down.
Oh see Bam.
I mean it doesn't get any more perfect
because it hits side Dick.
See if you get hit with.
Today's cups are so much better than the
cups we had when we were kids because
the cups we had.
If you played.
Did you play any contact sports?
Lacrosse.
So when they have to put those cups in
the jock strap,
those fuckers kind of floated around a
little bit.
Oh,
they were a terrible where one half the
time I can Lacrosse I stopped wearing a
cup because it was because I would just.
They would just start hurting my balls,
like that little line part of that,
like the edge would sometimes just get
above the ball and then one time I got
hit by like a 90 mile,
an hour shot and the ball goes 90 miles
an hour.
Yeah.
And it's just hard rubber.
Ninety miles.
I did.
I use those things for massage.
Uh,
they're crazy.
Yeah.
He would take one of those Lacrosse
Paul's,
you lie on your back folks,
if anybody,
if you have like,
back soreness and like,
especially if you don't want to pay
someone to massage you,
if you can take the pain,
you can do it yourself.
Take a Lacrosse ball or we have those
other balls.
Uh,
they,
what do they mean?
Who makes them row?
Yes.
Rogue makes some rogue.
Athletics makes them,
they're fucking awesome.
They're called um,
a wad.
Supernovas Jamie.
Go grab one of those.
We've got it like right outside the
door.
Do you know what that thing is?
How do these guys can throw like 1:20
right there out of their mind?
Oh,
it's,
it's psychotic because it got the
leverage of it.
And it's also a sport where you get
super good at and then what you don't
even have a fucking career until if that
guy.
I mean there's guys that are probably
like just fucking aces at that shit,
but they can't go into the nfl,
nhl or the.
I mean there's nothing.
There was nothing now there Jamie.
Anyway,
so they make them.
I think Kelly started invented it,
but they,
I'm sorry if you,
if that's not correct,
but they uh,
I know Kelly star,
it was the one of the first guys to
suggest using a Lacrosse ball and you
take this lacrosse ball,
that's the Wad Supernova,
but you can use a cross ball.
I use one all the time.
I take it with me on the road because
it's super little.
But you take one of those hard little
fuckers and just lay it on the ground
and then bridge over it like a wrestling
bridge.
Just put all your weight into that
recall ball and just roll it up and down
like any kind of not you have in your
bag as painful as fuck.
I need some backstabbing.
Like that's the six,
seven back is not fun after a certain
age just starts.
Baxter,
temporary.
They're like tires.
You could wear those fuckers out.
You have to be careful and you have to
do maintenance work like backs or like
one of the most
common things that people enjoy and it
changed their life.
Like if you hurt your hand it sucks,
but it probably isn't going to change
your life like a back thing.
Will he break your hand if you've ever
broken a hand?
It's weird.
I broke my arm once.
I remember I was a little kid and I had
an a cast and I was like,
God,
I didn't learn how to write with my left
hand and it really sunk in my head for
strokes.
If you,
if you're ambidextrous,
it lowers your chances of having a
stroke.
Really?
Yes.
My uh,
my uh,
uncles and anesthetists or
anesthesiologists and he was like,
dude,
just write your name with your left hand
a lot.
And he said that there's something about
that that keeps the neuroplasticity
better.
Is it only writing your name is only
writing or other things as well?
I think it's just having the skill hand
switch.
Yeah.
That's funny you say that because they
say that that's one of the best ways to
get good at a skill is to practice it
with your opposite side.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Like um,
they say that with striking that when
you learn how to strike,
say like if you stand orthodox means
your left hand is Ford.
When I say striking him in martial arts,
when you stand with your left hand
forward,
usually guys do that because there are
powerful and the right hand.
But if they switched it,
like if you're a right handed person and
you put the power,
the backhand in the left side,
it comes out super awkward to me.
To this day I've been doing martial arts
most of my life and my left hand is just
straight dog shit.
Throw a left out of the bag.
It looks so awkward and Clunky,
but my right hand is pretty stout.
I thought.
Yeah,
for piano,
it's like that with the melody and the
guy tried to play songs with melodies on
the lefthand and it's so hard that I
have to almost relearn piano I would
imagine.
Yeah.
I mean because like you're thinking in a
language,
right?
You just don't think it's all I played
since I was so young and it's so fast
that you can't possibly think.
And so then like sometimes I'll forget
the way,
like a box songs going and it's almost
like that south park with Cartman,
like you have to start from the
beginning.
Yeah.
Because I don't know how to just jump in
because I don't,
it's just,
it's just instinct.
I don't even know what I'm doing.
Well,
you're the only.
The only argument for keeping the piano
on stage at the Improv.
And Craig Robinson for Craig Robinson,
sometimes it brings keyboards with them
places.
That's a good point.
You're not really,
uh,
bring a keyboard on the road.
Guy.
Aria.
I,
if they don't have a piano,
no,
usually they provide it,
but every now and then they just won't.
They're like,
they just forget one when you're in town
or how do you,
how do you work at like the Improv and
funny bones usually do that,
but if I'm doing like an obscure club,
they'll be like,
well,
it's a contract,
you know,
and uh,
and I don't mind because I just,
I usually go to like best buy or
something and then I'll either return it
or give it to a kid or something.
It's funny when someone just doesn't
honor a contract.
I had a guy once a week for it.
Yeah.
I had a club once and like specifically
we laid out that everyone has to have a
seat.
You can have standing room like in the
back of this place.
And he was like,
well then you're going to make less
money.
I'm like,
that's okay because this way at least I
know the show will be good.
Like I've,
I went to see doug's.
Dan helped me in a couple of friends and
uh,
it was at a place where I had to stand
long
time ago and I remember going,
Oh,
this blows right?
Like,
this isn't even half as good as sitting
down.
It's terrible.
So from then on,
like I used to go to,
um,
house of Blues,
those are infamous for it.
They'd have a big seating area in the
front and then to the side they have
this open bar area and you would just go
on stage talking at a bar.
I mean it was like people were just
talking.
It's like they're moving,
they're standing,
look,
and you can do that by the way.
You can get into that road gig mentality
and go up there,
but it's a different thing.
The road gig mentality.
You've got to be prepared for the road
gig.
Yeah.
You have to be prepared for not getting
crowd consent.
Yes.
You know,
and I,
I like a lot of crowd can set where I'm
like,
listen,
you gotta kiss back or we can't do
Doggie.
You also have to be willing to.
You have to understand that there's
going to be like randoms.
John,
you want a beer?
You want a shot?
Totally hear that.
You're going to hear that in the middle
of punchlines setups.
If there's anything that requires quiet,
like there's any like weird bit,
we have like a long pause,
like throw that bit out nuance that
ain't going to work,
but you could do it.
But anyway,
this guy,
um,
he just said,
well,
I could sell more tickets this way.
I got there and we make this work
workout,
right?
Signed the contracts the whole deal.
I get there.
People are standing.
I mean,
like a hundreds of people.
And I go,
what the fuck dude?
And he goes,
well,
you know,
when Blah,
blah,
please here.
You know,
she always loves people.
Stand in the back.
I go,
what does that mean?
We have a contract.
I go,
you know,
we had a contract,
right?
And he just looks at me and I go,
come on man.
What the cause is excused.
He's like,
he just looked at me.
we're here.
We're doing this show.
This is what we did.
I sold extra tickets.
I fucked you.
You mother fucker.
You was like,
I'm not motivated by the same shit as
human.
I want the audience to have a good
experience.
You just want more cash.
There was still made plenty of money.
We're still,
we're talking about the difference
between like,
I think it was like 300 to 500 seats,
so 300 seeds,
seeding or you could do 500 years,
200 standing.
But they filled the whole back of this
era because he had a big bar area,
like a big long area and that whole back
area too.
To me it's mostly a place they have
bands right now.
So I've eaten shit with a standing only
because I wasn't,
I didn't make the adjustment pre show,
you know,
so in my mind I'm like I'm doing standup
comedy and I go out there and I'm like I
should be a pink floyd cover band
tonight.
Who wants to hear the wall?
You've got to have a different kind of
energy.
You have like almost like a carnival
barker energy.
You know what I mean?
Like you got to get those people
interested in paying attention.
Yeah.
Like when I was at a renaissance fair
heckler in high school,
that was my job,
like in the stock and people would pay
money to throw tomatoes at me.
So it was all just figuring out what
someone's vulnerability was and just
exploiting it and just,
it was carnival barking too.
I was working with only the guy's name
was boob and he was a,
a boob full name who you go,
I think.
And he was a,
uh,
just gypsies,
Gypsies,
and I was just trying to beat the joust
and I get big crowds because it was all
about letting them win occasionally
because you couldn't just be like,
oh,
that tomato didn't hurt.
You have to be humiliated.
Right,
right,
right.
Even play it up.
Right.
Did I get hammered and let him slap me
in the face for like 20 bucks,
17 I drink,
meet and just be out.
Did you get hurt that way?
I know dude knows how to slap good.
Well,
there was this one levels,
that slap game,
but there was a.
yeah,
like there'd be like a biker.
It'd be like,
no,
I'm gonna throw a rock.
And I'm like,
Shit.
And I'd run to the cornfield.
Oh,
let's talk to some people did knock you
the fuck out with a slop.
We use lab.
It'd be like just some Dick.
And you never know who that dickhead.
That's true.
That's super.
Like the Diaz brothers.
Like you're like,
oh,
you're a normal guy.
Oh,
you're the toughest dude in the world.
Yeah.
You do not want them slapping you.
Right.
Especially if they know they're going to
slap you.
It sounded like an instinct.
Like in the middle you said something
stupid to them.
They're like,
what?
They line up.
But if they like line up and get ready,
what is this guy doing?
He's letting the guy slap him,
but they haven't got a slap off.
Come on.
These go are pretty big on the Internet.
Oh my God.
Everyone gets knocked out.
People get knocked the fuck out.
That guy just got kod because this guy
hit him right on the job.
Oh wait a minute.
So who went the gift that that was?
This was first I come in and.
And so the second,
the second guy killed them.
That's even more impressive.
He took a shot.
Watch this.
Oh my God.
That dude's out fucking cold.
I hope there was a mat behind him or
someone to catch him.
Probably not
less drama,
just because it's the little button and
you know,
it still shakes the brain.
Yeah,
that's terrible.
Like that guy's brain got jolted there.
His next spun around.
His brain sloshed back and forth and
said,
I'm so screwed.
I'm going to get all that shit when I'm
older from the tomatoes.
You probably will a little for real
tomatoes.
Do you think hit you $10,000
a day pool?
Oh No.
They miss a lot that somebody was
thrown.
I was hit hard maybe,
but I never got knocked out.
I want to talk to you about this.
Do you think that that might have
something to do with why you're
impulsive?
You're very impulsive.
I think.
Wait a good way.
I think you're serious,
but you,
you,
what?
You say some shit online on twitter.
You're fucking super impulsive.
Like I laugh at him.
I'm like,
this dude just goes for it.
I don't know about.
I,
I think,
uh,
it's just like the art of,
I don't know,
there is an art to saying fucked up shit
and that's one of the things I really
appreciate you about you.
So you're a very smart guy,
but you also appreciate the art of
saying fucked up shit.
It's one of the things that we do and it
doesn't,
it doesn't get respected enough because
especially today,
man,
you are fucking dancing a fine line
between razor blades and crocodiles.
You offend today.
People are just super,
Super Cali Audi because I just got a
bull horn sometimes.
I just felt like,
I dunno,
I just wanted,
I just wanted to keep
comedy going mad for myself.
I didn't want to.
I just think our job is to not have a
line,
you know,
I try to be kind,
I don't want to like.
But at the same time it's like I have to
figure like our job is hyperbole.
Like we work in a truth dungeon and it's
like my,
my,
my thing is I might be wrong,
but I'm not lying and I'm wrong a lot.
But in the moment,
yeah,
I think what's super important is that
you.
You've made a real good distinction that
you try not to be cruel and.
Exactly.
That's I do too.
And sometimes you miss.
Right?
That's another thing about this working
without a net shit boy.
Sometimes you miss for sure,
for sure.
Something you shouldn't have said,
especially in live shows you try,
you just the impulse comes into your
mind and you go for it.
But under careful consideration,
if you sat down and thought about it for
a few minutes,
you're like,
oh no,
I can't do this bit this and that would
have people misconstrue.
What if someone took it out of context
would.
If someone doesn't understand that this
is what I'm doing,
I'm just pushing buttons to people who
know him pushing buttons.
I'm not trying to be cruel.
They're in the game versus just random
casualties.
And also I think that the outrage Ponzi
scheme people,
I don't even.
I don't even care.
Like I think a lot of people feign
outrage because they don't understand,
but they still want to retain power.
But then there's people that actually
like,
I'll hurt them and that's when I'm like,
oh no,
did I?
Because my problem is every now and then
I'll reverse virtue signaling where it's
almost like I'll go farther intense that
I normally would have because I'm trying
to counteract virtue signaling and then
I'm like,
well I'm throwing a punch at someone
that other people don't even might not
see.
And then now I just am a crazy guy.
Like super aggressive.
Yeah,
I've been talking about that a lot about
trump that I think that all these people
attacking trump in many ways,
they actually kind of ramp up as
behavior for the.
Yeah,
it's the,
it's the if you read up black redneck
white liberal by Thomas Soul.
No,
it's unbelievable.
We bring this up,
the law.
Why do I feel maybe I think someone else
did well.
Cowen recommended it to me.
It might have been so,
uh,
is like one of the most read.
Well read guys.
It's unreal.
He's just always reading books.
Yeah.
And he's getting into wine,
which is one of the hardest hobbies.
I can't do that.
I can't even,
there's not enough time just to,
so like pbr shit,
my foot fucking axe.
But uh,
I can't.
A PBR has a wonderful flavor of it.
So I love keeping.
If pbr was like really respected as some
like light ale from like Germany,
like if you've got a good batch of Pbi,
like wow,
it's kind of weird,
sort of aluminum me taste.
It sounds like.
It's just like they do like the
condescending for Annunciation.
Like they know Mr.
Listen,
pabst blue ribbon with some fucking
stone crabs and some butter and maybe
some fries with a lot of salt on them.
Come on son.
There's nothing better.
I mean look,
it's not the same kind of beer.
It's people are flavor snobs.
Like they want you to be in the IPA.
The IPA is,
can you handle the bitter?
What about caviar?
And she like to like stuff that tastes
like shit.
And they used to feed lobsters to
prisoners,
like not that long.
Well
Dude,
lobsters,
God damn delicious,
delicious.
But it's like,
who gets to make the call?
Well,
you know what the difference is?
Lobsters with and without butter.
That's the difference was dealt with
butter and lobster.
This like butter,
make some shit just way better.
And one of the things that makes way
better as lobster for sure there is no
god damn question.
And lobsters are,
you know,
it's essentially a bug.
It's a big old bug.
It's a giant Pete on this shit.
Eating beetle.
They're not much different than bugs
that walk around on the surface of the
earth.
They're just water bugs.
And I think we also liked the task of
like cracking and splitting it like
artichokes.
Tape deliciousness right there.
Crabs.
What kind of grabs those?
Jamie?
Look,
God damn good stipend.
Pbr and crabs and that's it.
A pabst blue ribbon can because nothing
gets crabs that spice on the outside and
lemon and Ipa can take you for a turn.
Like my wife.
This like here have some odd because I
usually come in like if I,
if I get a little buys,
I'll come in,
you know,
and she wanted to hang and I'm out there
just drinking the,
staring into a fire.
And she gave me this ipa called dog fish
and it's 18 percent alcohol and like
three beers and I'm like blacked out
because I was just drinking.
I'm like,
Beers.
And I'm like,
Oh,
three beers now come in.
That's so unnecessary.
And it was like to do that to people.
I don't know.
It was like,
it's like spike and someone.
I was like,
roofing,
please.
Here's the thing.
Like,
it's you can't.
This is one of my.
I had a bit about this,
about my problem and pot gummy bears.
He said,
one of the problems is it looks like a
regular fucking gummy bear in my brain.
Thinks,
oh,
I could just fucking beat the shit out
of those gummy bears.
I getting five or 10 of them.
False representation could just Jack
your world.
There's a video I put on instagram of
Least Siad.
Have you seen that video?
One by one design,
put it up and he's got a,
a video that they took from Joey d as
the Church of what's happening now.
And Lisa is literally the physical
example that you would use if someone
who's too high.
What's too hot?
You like this?
This is too high.
Like look at him there.
He's got his eyes closed.
Give me some volume,
Jamie.
We're all talking.
They're playing some music and look at
him.
Look at him.
Look at his eyes.
Fade new now.
By the way,
he knew what he was supposed to be at
the podcast,
not woke them up to do a podcast.
He left the camera on himself to himself
and he's just.
He's so paranoid right now.
He's freaking the fuck out.
He throws his head back.
He said,
Jesus,
I can't do this anymore.
I can't work.
I can't work with you.
Joey Diaz.
He's just thinking right now.
Demons just waiting for him to close his
eyes and go to sleep.
I can't.
I can't keep into the demons over him.
Just scratching at the ceiling,
just waiting for the lights to turn out
and his eyes closed and they're going to
go through his fucking mouth.
Penetrate his body.
And I've been that exact guy on
that exact podcast.
Yeah,
Joe,
I couldn't handle it,
man.
He's a different animal.
I love that dude.
He's the best,
but he's a different animal.
You can,
you know,
don't,
don't try to outdo him ever.
I was just trying to hang.
He was the one who had mercy on me,
which I thought was incredible because
I'm like,
Yo,
let me just grab another little stores
done,
and he's like,
no way doc.
You're going to fucking be nice to you.
Put like what you said about the gummy
bears.
It's like,
yeah,
it's almost like the false
representation is the thing I don't like
more than the representation.
That's enough and that's why I get so
pissed about certain scandals because
someone's a hypocrite versus other ones
where I'm like,
ah man,
I feel bad for that guy.
Right.
I know what you're saying.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
In did you see the hear the podcast I
had the other day with Jamie Kilstein?
Yes.
He's a good dude,
man.
The way he came clean about all that
stuff and just talked about how it all
got away from him as like a social
justice warrior and describing in like
really honest and I think super brave
the way he described like this charge
that he would get after going after
someone and calling someone a racist and
getting other people to go after and
trying to get them fired
to gave me a good perspective on myself.
It's like when did the concept of the
attack dog where it's this like an
understood thing where you're going to
attack for the group and then it's like
then you start seeking approval from
strangers and how much of it is actually
your own opinion at that point.
And that's a very,
very profound thing to think about.
We,
we have a series in our brain is filled
with the series of reward systems that
are in place,
right?
Like there's,
there's a need for approval from the
tribe.
There's the need for,
you know,
sexually reproduce.
There's the need to accomplish tasks,
has a need to avoid probation,
and we have all these reward systems,
right?
Where like your body and your,
your,
your organism will reward you with a
positive feeling for reinforcing some of
the patterns of behavior that are
necessary for survival.
Right?
Like the ability to run away from
something when you're scared,
when you get scared and you freak out
that as a jolt of Goji juice,
right?
You'll buy that Geico insurance.
Fuck you ready to run man.
Have you ever been like legitimately
scared for your life and have that
feeling?
Fuck yeah man,
it's terrible.
Fine.
Right?
And that's more powerful than,
than desire.
And I think that's one thing we're
facing right now as a society because
it's just planes of Africa running from
a lion versus towards a banana.
Like what's,
what's crazier?
So I think that that's a way to
supercharge a population into buying a
bunch of dumb shit.
Well,
I still think this is a very important
point that I think a lot of us it takes
a long time to realize is that these
reward systems that we have set up,
right?
Like these patterns that feel good to
follow through with like you know,
the way we handle conflict and
especially at the d,
the need to push yourself and stress
yourself out like some sort of physical
exercise.
I've really feel like that those things
like if you can help them,
like if you could give them their fuel
and a positive way,
you don't get any of the negative
aspects of it,
but you get the positive aspects of it
because like especially like the
physical one,
I,
I really believe this from my own
experiences.
We all have physical requirements for
movement and we don't.
We don't give those physical
requirements.
We don't feed the body correctly with
those movements.
And what happens is it gets angst and it
gets weird.
Everybody gets freaked out and it starts
getting fat.
It starts feeling like shit.
And one of the reasons why it's not
functioning right,
it's because we didn't properly manage
movement,
like making sure your body is getting
exercise,
like put some stress on it so that it
can recover and be stronger and maintain
a certain level of strength.
Because if you don't put any stress on
it,
it stops working and if it stops
working,
you start your.
You start sagging and deteriorating.
And here's the big one.
Maybe you're an intellectual.
Maybe you don't want to have anything to
do with physical stuff because you don't
think you think of it as a base thing.
That fucking body has a giant influence
on your mind.
Eight apps,
no separation.
There's no separation.
It is,
and it is just a discipline issue and
there's nothing else.
It's.
I'm not saying it should be a
bodybuilder.
I'm not saying you should go out there
and fucking run marathons or do
anything.
Even the super stressful,
but do some sit ups,
do some pushups,
do some chin ups.
If you can do some,
some running up hills,
pickup some heavy stuff.
Move it around and do it regularly.
Do it all the time.
And do it even if you have no desire
whatsoever to look good naked,
just do it to make your body last
longer.
Yes.
It's natural anti depressant.
Like I used to live in the Czech
Republic and there was no gems there.
What we do in there studying history and
there is no jams and I would have like
a.
I didn't feel safe in certain areas,
jogging because it was just intense so I
would just jump up and down.
That's it.
I would play like disco or something and
just manically jump up and down and I
feel awesome.
I had this dumb idea once a few years
back.
I was like,
well,
if you just jumped all the time and you
kept jumping,
wouldn't you get better at trumping like
wouldn't you?
Like you get stronger and stuff.
It's a matter of like how many reps you
do.
You don't like.
How high could you wind up jumping?
Is there a point of no return?
Dude?
You're telling to a six slash seven guy
who can't dunk,
who's jumped a lot to try and get up
there.
I think I can get really good at long
distance running,
but I don't have the twitch to go up and
I've tried man.
Well I feel like a cement potato.
I can't jump at all.
I can't dunk for shit.
Married little ups.
I could endure some video yesterday of
the highest jump I've ever seen by a guy
that didn't look that tall.
His top of his head.
You know,
the,
the verticals thing.
He had the top one that's unreal.
Like mosquito eggs and spoke video.
Yeah,
I've saw this one dude that was
practicing on those.
You ever see those?
Uh,
the Plyo bags,
they're the
plyo boxes,
but the top of them is like a very soft
foam mushy.
So they.
Yeah,
this guy was jumping those and it,
it looked like there was like,
there was wires attached to his hips.
I'm like,
what are they doing?
A yanking him up to this guy because he
was jumping like six feet straight up in
the air and landing on this things.
It's like,
wait a minute,
you can,
people can do that.
It's like you have jumped privilege.
Oh look at this guy.
Whoa,
that must feel so awesome.
That guy is.
That's a four foot vertical,
right?
Is that a forefoot vertical?
Not sure I don't.
I don't know the exact height of the top
of the backboard.
Know the highest vertical than anybody's
ever jumped.
If you had to guess,
let's take 51 inches.
That's a good guess.
I'll say 53 just for the fuck of it,
but just based on your guests being
really good and awesome thing you do for
people is you motivate people to learn
new shit,
which is crucial for a neuroplasticity.
I'm very happy that I do that,
but I only do it because I'm interested
in it myself.
Dude,
you got me into shoe.
I'm like,
yeah,
God,
look at this dude.
Sixty.
So you got it.
You got it bro.
Goddamn Leo.
Now Marshall,
he's a Cuban professional volleyball
player and it said to have a 50 inch
vertical jump.
The next guy is a.
The doors Yanni.
He's a professional dunker with slam
nation did not exist and is set to hold
the world record in the vertical at 60
inches.
Okay.
Here's what I don't like is said is said
is used twice.
It's like legend has it that.
See there's some shitty journalism or
you're not telling me the truth.
You're just telling me some rumor
bullshit.
Here's a matter of getting it on on
tape.
I guess.
Here's a 63 or whatever the fuck it is,
man.
I don't.
Don't diminish this man's accomplished
or not,
but I got up.
Jamie got this.
I know what you want to see this guy do
it.
Hold on.
I will see this guy do it is insane.
He's really gonna.
Jump that high.
That's over his head out 63 inches.
That's fucking dude.
You know,
you know you're good at something when
you're.
When you're like,
you have a crowd for like a gym
movement.
Here he goes,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
That's fucking insane.
What's that dude's name?
Ryan Moodie or is he?
No,
Evan Unger.
60 three point five inch box.
Jump.
World record.
Hold on,
go back please.
May Thirteenth,
2016.
That dude's a beast.
That's ridiculous.
By the way,
to put that energy into something
positive.
Son.
Just jumping up on rubber tires,
being the CEO of a billion dollar
company kid,
he gets some serious focus.
Said you're putting your all your
interest on jumping high.
It's like a cross.
It's a cross.
Everyone jump highest.
Okay.
You did it.
You've proven now move forth and you
know there's no struggle.
There's no pro and box jumping goes
back.
Yeah,
but you said it goes back to the cross.
Look man,
you're talking to a dude who spent most
of his young days doing taekwondo.
There's very few things.
Do you.
Have you got that to us?
Kicked Torque?
Yeah,
but I'm saying like as far as like
putting your energy into something that
you could do with your life.
Right?
I'll do.
That was a history major.
I'm the guy that I have is like conduit
Constantine.
I get more drinks.
Like what?
The House that get me.
I always loved those guys at the bar
that know way more than me.
Like what?
Hold on.
What book?
It was always like some obscure
bartender who could tell you some crazy
shit about Napoleon.
You're like,
wait a minute.
Like we were talking about Napoleon
before,
like Napoleon wasn't short,
he was short for today,
but he's a,
he's an inch shorter than me,
is five slash seven,
which is very tall for a person who is
starving to death.
Right,
right,
right.
Everybody was back then,
like nobody got good food.
It was like North Korea is now.
It's like South Korea and North Korea.
The height difference is massive.
It's so sad,
man.
You know,
all those little people from like the
civil war days,
an average man was like 130 pounds.
The really little tiny fellows.
Yeah.
You see the uniforms and like a museum
and it just looks like smurfs.
Yeah man.
You know,
that's all.
It's all just about food.
Is it both me up nutrients,
you know,
it's,
it's a dark thing to think of that.
This is cheers my brother.
Just man.
Thanks for having me.
Thank you.
Thanks for being a fan said dark thing
to think that like nutrients held back
like the physical development of people.
Like they had so little food that they
weren't growing.
Right.
That's so crazy.
It's not like they were,
you know,
like there was supposed to be that
small,
oh my God,
this guy's a giant.
Leave comments soldier a look at this.
According to historian bell,
I Wiley who pioneered the study of the
civil war common soldier.
The average Yank or reb was a white
native born farmer protested single
between 18 and 29.
He said about five foot eight inches
tall and weighed 143 pounds.
Okay.
That's not as small as I thought because
that's average.
Now I got like five,
five and I think they were saying that
the average weight was like 125 pounds
with the average height was much
smaller.
Maybe it wasn't the civil war.
It was the war of 18,
12.
I think.
Civil war,
I mean we're on a dollar a day and
today's money until like 1890.
They were broke,
man.
I mean my mom,
her parents had a dirt floor,
dirt.
My parents were born in America,
but my grandparents came over to America
from Italy when they were really young.
Like I think my grandpa was a before the
teenage years and and he was telling me
about the brutality of life on a farm
when you're poor,
during the depression,
you know,
about how,
how we learned to kill rabbits with his
bare hands,
you know,
how you would explain to me a snapper
rabbits snack and you're looking in the
guy's eyes that didn't know whether or
not members of his family would starve
to death exactly like this.
There was a different world back then.
Man.
Stakes.
Yeah.
No one's worried about pronouns.
My grandfather was a very kind and
gentle man,
sort of belied
like almost the rest of my family and,
and,
and his,
his start in life because he,
you know,
he was born during a very,
very,
very difficult time and he was just a
really kind demand who liked to read
books.
He was like the gentle one of my family.
So cool.
He was like,
I lived with him when I was a kid when I
was just moving to New York when I had
to leave Boston and I got a manager and
my manager lived in New York who I'm
still with this day and I was like
barely out of the open mic days and um,
I couldn't afford to live in New York by
myself.
I tried to figure it out,
like how much money I had,
very little saved up and I basically
just went to New York with my car and
some clothes and my grandpa let me stay
at his place.
And uh,
it was weird man because my grandmother
was dying.
She had a stroke and they gave her 72
hours and she lived for 12 years.
Ice.
They thought she was going to be dead.
That like you say your goodbyes,
get the family to fly to her,
you know,
she,
she had a bad aneurysm and she lived
forever.
It's crazy.
So your grandpa took care of her.
He took care of her and I was living
with the two of them while that was
going on.
So like while I was going as transition
in my life,
like the most exciting thing,
like literally that's ever happened to
me,
I get this real legit manager and I
started thinking maybe I can actually do
this,
like maybe I can actually be a comic
because when I was living in Boston I
was doing all sorts of other jobs and it
was never like a professional.
I never had a full.
Like I never had enough work where I
could 100 percent be a comic and I've
only been doing it for like three years.
Right.
So it was just grinding,
constantly grinding,
doing a bunch of different day jobs.
And so when this opportunity came,
I was like,
Holy Shit,
I can't believe this is real.
And as like my life was starting to go
into this crazy place,
I spent a good solid three months,
maybe four living with my grandfather
while my grandmother was dying and
that's where I live.
So I'd come home with them and talk to
them all the time.
And they lived in a neighborhood that
used to be a predominantly Italian
American neighborhood in Newark.
But it deteriorated slowly but surely
until it was like a really.
It went from a black people.
It's just like they did a thing called
blockbusting.
You ever heard that story?
You know a blog post.
They're trying to get them.
Yeah,
they're trying to.
They did that where they would move into
neighborhoods and I don't know whether
or not it was true or there was doing.
They were doing it to capitalize on
something that was true or whether they
instigated it,
but they would essentially go door to
door and they would say black people are
moving in,
sell your house now.
And most of my grandparents families
around them sold their house.
And my grandfather was like,
I like black people,
fuck off.
Literally just shut his door.
That's awesome.
Man.
Grandfather was one of those guys as
long as he has a gate and there's a lock
on the gate,
like everything's good in the world.
And he,
he had like.
So when I would visit him like he had
neighbors,
like the next door neighbor right
next door got arrested for selling
crack.
This kid had an audi parked in the
driveway.
They broke through his house with a
battering ram.
That was like right before I moved in.
This is awesome,
man.
Yeah.
But I was watching their transition to
death essentially in my transition to
life at the same time.
Yeah,
I'd tell them somewhat similar.
I mean that that's to me right now,
like,
that's so profound because like now that
I'm like,
I have a family and thinking about my
wife and he watched the notebook and
you're like,
oh shit.
But like,
my best friend died on my birthday that
year.
I was out here a snowboarding and it was
right as I got like punk and the show
punked and he like is the one who got me
into standup.
And it was like,
that was so bittersweet,
man.
It was like,
it was like the fragility of life as
you're given this weird ego shot.
Just just was like,
it was so intense.
A good friend of mine died of an
overdose.
Same thing.
Died of an overdose.
Like,
really?
Uh,
I can't say I was out here maybe three
or four years.
He died maybe five at the most.
Uh,
I spent New Year's Eve,
y two k on the phone with him because we
were wondering whether or not the world
will.
Then we were just having fun laughing
and then he died.
He died of a drug overdose and I found
out about it like secondhand.
Somebody found out about it through
somebody else and they called me up and
they asked me if I heard and I said,
what happened?
Are you sure?
And they said,
yeah.
They found his body in a hotel room and
on.
Oh,
on real rough.
It was rough.
That was the hardest one next to my
grandpa.
Those,
that was the hardest one.
Well,
Phil Hartman was pretty God damn hard
to.
That was a hard one.
I recently lost a,
got a heroin.
He was a vet and it was like,
and you saw it coming,
but it was tragic because his ptsd was
so bad,
but it was like,
to.
The story was a,
he was a d one baseball player at
everything going for him.
His Dad dies,
he wants to join the marines.
He's unbelievable at being a sniper,
you know,
they go through how in Afghanistan he
gets on heroin,
ends up in my town,
we become like best friends with my
brother because like a lot of vets want
to do tree work because they need that.
Every man needs a purpose,
you know,
and it's like a lack of purpose for like
true warrior hero types,
his death and so like that extreme
nature of climbing up trees and hauling
lumber and stuff.
We'd all do it together.
And,
and that's what I also like comedy
because the honesty of it,
you know,
the dude shot tons and tons of people.
So it's like that feeling of constant
judgment and guilt and pride and guilt.
Comedy was like a relief for him and
then he just died of heroin man and it
was like,
you get the this because you know,
I got him a gym membership and all this
shit and we were all like rooting for
him because he's this beautiful man.
But like there's just a moral injuries
that just can take a toll.
And that was,
that was brutal.
Yeah.
There's some injuries of the mind that
are probably more devastating injuries
to the body,
you know,
and I think that's uh,
that's one of the things that we
overlook,
what we can't see.
We think about what we can see,
like,
oh,
that guy got shot in the shoulder,
but we don't look at,
Oh,
and watch 10 people die in a fire,
you know,
like,
we don't think of that as an injury.
But I mean think about like,
I've,
I've had some friends that were
paramedics and they'll tell you like,
accents.
They roll up on suicides that they roll
up on and just after awhile you're like,
oh my God,
you feel so vulnerable.
And one of the things that he said is
like,
a lot of people that do that work or
like a very sexually promiscuous,
they just don't give a fuck.
Yeah.
And they also want to develop the
develop dark humor,
gallows humor,
you know,
like,
um,
my buddy quinn from the impractical
jokers used to be a New York City
firefighter.
And so we did one of my podcasts
together.
I mean,
we've been friends since my space.
these guys are salted,
the earth man,
they're the fucking greatest dude's like
great statements.
Like say we've been friends since my
budget.
We used to write each other about our
sketches and shit and it's like,
that dude is seeing just kids torched,
you know,
and,
and he's like,
and they had to joke about it.
If not,
you're going to just blow your brains
out.
So yeah.
And then you come home to your own
family,
you know?
Yeah.
It's like,
look at England after World War Two.
that's,
I think that's what spawned so much
great music.
Some great art is,
you know,
their dads all died man and it's like
for their cities are getting bombed and
out of that comes this like desire to
live in the moment and to just be able
to say and do whatever the fuck you can
before you die.
I think you're totally right.
I think that's the case with Roman art
as well,
right?
I mean why is there so much artistic
expression back then?
Why?
Why were people so determined to put
their emotions down on campus?
Those emotions were like hurricane
swirling in your brain,
visions of people getting cut in half by
swords and arrows piercing sternums
choking to death on their own blood and
fucking hordes of barbarians coming over
the top of the hill with the horses,
swinging axes like,
whoa,
that was real shit back then know
someone with a blue check mark is mad at
me.
In fact,
then people are just getting their heads
chopped off and you know,
I've been thinking about this a lot
lately with this Kevin Spacey thing is
that pedophilia is horrific.
We all agree it's.
It's terrifying.
It's,
it's,
it's so devastating because as we were
talking about before,
if someone gets shot,
you could see the wound.
If someone gets raped by an act or when
they're 12 years old,
like how do you fix that?
Right?
What,
what is that?
What kind of psychic wound is that?
And what I was thinking is it's really
fascinating to me that we,
we pretty much acknowledged that
pederasts were commonplace in the 15th
century,
the Twelfth Century,
the 13th century,
the 14th century,
this way,
way into the 18 hundreds.
And then when you go with the Catholic
Church,
I mean it is,
if you're a Catholic,
you shut your fucking iphone off right
now.
You know what I'm saying?
Nobody raised Catholic and that was as
well.
Don't get your panties in a bundle.
It is a religion built on kid fucking.
It is a religion dude.
It's all about as a giant history of
that and it's because they,
they,
they wouldn't let the priests have
families based on land ownership and
some of these moves can take a beautiful
religion and make it really dark.
And there was more than that.
It wasn't just that they didn't let him,
they didn't want to fuck women because
they were a God damn rock stars.
The guys who held the Bible and could
lead literally read it right?
The average person could relax.
They're all reading German and all these
different languages.
I wouldn't.
Martin Luther.
Have you ever heard the prophets of
doom?
Yeah.
Prophets of doom.
Dan Carlin is one of my favorite fucking
human beings and several lived and his
podcast.
Hardcore history is a national treasure.
Because I've learned more about history
and more about like the mon goals and a
World War II and fucking everything,
but his podcast on Martin Luther and the
trend,
the first literal translations of the
Bible that regular common folk could
read who've lost their minds.
They're like,
Jesus was poor too.
Guys dependent wars killed hundreds of
thousands of people.
Imagine a world folks were until.
What was it like the 15 hundreds?
Yeah,
mid fifties.
It was round Gutenberg,
so that was like a 15 hundreds,
mid 15 Sinai when Martin Luther was 95
theses in deck,
but the bottom line is what he had done
was translate the Bible.
He Slang.
A lot of Dick guarantee wasn't doing
this because he just wanted people to be
free to October 31st,
so.
Oh Jesus Christ.
It was yesterday.
This is crazy.
Did.
It was after US sober October 500 years
ago.
By the way.
I'm feeling a toasty.
I feel so good right now.
Filled right back.
I was worried,
man.
I was worried that if I smoked a joint,
I'd be like,
Oh my God,
I'm gonna.
Die a worm of paranoia.
Thinking about girls,
I figured in high school,
for me it's the adipose man.
I like,
I don't smoke every now and that if like
there's someone I trust,
I know as good we will like Seattle,
Seattle's that.
I'm like,
this is just flesh,
but that should make,
makes me like real.
Um,
so this was the 15 hundreds,
15,
15 is I would just a 15,
17.
So think about that like before then
that we're only talking that we're
literally only talking about 500 years
ago.
Yeah,
exactly.
That was the last information overload.
So think about 500 years in terms of the
life of the human species is mere of
mere blip and one of the reasons why the
Catholic Church was able to get away
with just translating things to people
where they couldn't read it is because
that's how fucking everybody did it.
They all did it that way.
You would go to some place and some guy
would tell you what the sacred stuff
would be and you'd be like,
okay,
cool.
Like how many people actually got ahold
of it and read it all day and,
and studied it.
And made sure there was no
contradictions is why is this guy keep
fucking my wife Jesus.
The Catholics were like the buzzfeed.
They were banging everybody.
I guarantee you they had money.
They were allowed to have wives.
Like,
do you know that like early Pope's ran
armies?
Oh yeah,
I did.
They were nuts.
They had to go to France for a little
while to like,
you know,
because had so much heat on them because
it's what it fused with constantly.
It's when a fused with the Roman empire,
you got that Empire Shit because
Christianity is a beautiful.
Religion is more like mellow and
peaceful.
And,
and then you got constantine,
you know,
the Roman Empire is falling apart and
they wanted to get more favor of the
people.
So they just fuse the two together and
they're like,
you know,
they got,
the pope's gone crazy.
They ran armies.
That was one of the things that
happened.
Apparently there was a conflict.
I hope I'm not fucking this up.
It was from hardcore history.
There was a conflict where one of the
earlier pope's didn't want to send
troops to fight gang is con,
like there was a lot of confusion in the
early days of getting his con because
before getting,
Goddammit,
I've said it in the past,
if you heard it in the past,
I apologize for repeating myself,
but the wrath of Khan,
wrath of the con series of Dan Carlin
Sunrail streaks on real.
One of my favorite pieces of work,
whether it's a comedy,
a movie,
one of my favorite creations ever.
It's unreal.
It's amazing.
It literally changed my life.
It's like I got like a Harvard education
after paying for a state education for
free.
I know that in the game and then if you
want to get the wrath of the cons,
you could just buy it on itunes.
It's a dollar a show.
That's it.
It's so worth it and I think it's like
each one of them is at least an hour and
a half long.
Oh,
some are five.
The blitz or sick to get all of them.
The whole series,
right?
The series is fine,
but not an individual podcast like the
uh,
recent blitz a was over five about
nuclear war and the whole podcast by
itself is fine,
but yeah,
and then he just had the Gothic,
a genocide of the gothic Holocaust.
I was another fiber.
So gangster.
And he,
by the way,
he does this whole himself folks.
He edits it all himself.
So it was like that dollar is so worth
it and in my opinion,
he's like one of the most people just
don't know.
You know,
you're not hearing about this on CNN,
you not hear about this on Fox News and
it is a travesty.
It is one of the best ways for you to
learn about history because you learn
about it.
He gives you a broad,
detailed sense of the time.
He does it in a very entertaining way
that you want to keep tuning in and that
those memories stick to your brain.
There's an art to saying things
interesting and he has that old whole
series for 10 bucks.
It's so worth it.
That one and a half beers guys,
that's so worth it.
Whereas that is website Dan Carlin Doc.
Okay.
Um,
but you can also order it on itunes if
you have.
I don't have an android phone,
but if you have an eye I do,
but I don't use it.
But if you have an iphone you can order
it on itunes and it'll go straight to
your podcasts.
Yeah.
And there's another one that goes to the
oster front.
Mm.
Oh.
And he also has that old timey voice,
almost like the joker where he keeps
hitting you.
It's like what is a monument of?
Yes.
He's a great combination of
entertainment information and humility.
Like he's really humble.
He's like,
I'm not a historian,
but most of us think that the real.
And then I'll just the anabaptist
clearly when they purged wizard wizard,
so,
so important.
And I mean I've talked about them many
times in the past,
a point where I backed off because my
God talk about 10.
Carla too much.
That was brian red bands and one who got
me into it because I the only podcast I
listen to yours like maybe five,
four years ago.
That was the only one I really had and a
and I'm like,
Yo Redman,
what else should I listen to?
It just goes,
and I think it was just so fucked up and
he still like,
it was like that.
Just,
just,
just set me off a journey,
you know?
One another great one is Danieli Lily's
history on fire.
Listen to that.
That's good.
Plus you get a fantastic accent.
I mean,
Danielle,
he bullied his,
his,
his accent.
He's like,
Oh God,
like a super Italian accent.
I know.
I'm like,
this is kind of sexy.
So much that after this I'm not even gay
at all,
but this is why people will say,
and the Roman gods,
because they all talk to each other.
We were kind of wig red around that,
but it's stunning to me that what we
were originally talking about was like
how common being a pedophile was.
He was like super common.
That until there is history on fire
profess or about spartacus,
spudding kids.
He's a beautiful person too.
I love that guy.
Fucking great dude.
Um,
but it's,
it's amazing how recent it was where
that was taboo,
where you weren't,
where people like,
hey,
maybe we should stop fucking kids.
That's my,
that's my one.
Like I have a few rules in life,
but the number one is don't fuck the
kids.
Well,
it's 100 percent.
Number one,
don't hurt the children.
Don't hurt the children are physically.
Don't hurt them sexually.
Don't hurt him mentally.
Don't hurt the kids.
That's number one.
Feed.
Protect and teach what you are is the
result of some crazy shit that happened
to you and some awesome shit that
happened to you and your ability to
manage that fucking the land in between
the two that causes depression.
Yeah.
Between chaos and order.
Law and order.
Yeah.
I mean that's what our job is,
is to figure out a way to make the best
people we can and raise those people so
that those people are going to impact as
many people as they can in a positive
way.
And if this can be done,
look,
you got to realize that the people of
today,
we're were basically biologically the
same as the people that live in the
gangs con days.
But we couldn't be further apart in
terms of the way we look at the world.
It's our software programming.
Yeah,
exactly.
Think about how you are,
how Jamie is her,
most of the people we know are.
And then think about getting his cons
mob of savages that were just eating.
People are like,
uh,
Syria.
Uh,
Carlin gets into that.
It's a judgement at,
at Nineveh,
it's like these people were like public
scannings and burnings and because it
was just all about just the yoke of
oppression in your life was just pain
and you wanted to inflict that pain on
other people.
So you agreed to like,
there was like,
there,
there's like almost like a sort of an
evolutionary basis and staying as close
to people as you can while agreeing with
his little evidence as possible to
murder them all.
Just like we're like witch trials.
And one of the things that freaked me
out about Dan Carlin's history of the
Mongols thing was he started talking
about how there's speculation that
decimation like the term decimation came
from like a 100.
They would eat one of them.
Oh no way that they need.
Why would eat one?
There was speculation that some of the
Mongols like decimation,
like decimated and it's like destroying,
but would it really is like a desperate,
like this 10 people you kill one was run
out of supplies,
but that the Mongols would pick one
amongst them and they would eat them so
that the rest of the troops would
survive.
I was like,
that is so crazy.
And the guy was pretty hightest.
Like if you were above a wagon wheel,
you just cut your fucking head off.
Here's what decimation means.
The killing of one in every 10 of a
group of people as a punishment for the
whole group.
But that was just the punishment.
What Dan Carlin was talking about is
there's some people and maybe he doesn't
agree with them or maybe he does,
but some people believe it's possible.
The Mongols did this practice in order
to stay alive.
They definitely did.
They,
they used to suck the blood out of their
horses and they would add milk to it.
Yeah.
They're just,
they're hungry.
They're like,
oh,
I'm just going to suck some blood on his
horse.
Yeah,
that's how they stayed alive.
They would cut the blood,
like cut an artery fill like a jug with
blood and then they would milk them and
mix the blood and the milk together and
they would eat that.
And then their kids started getting soft
because they became quote unquote
Chinese.
So like they like a Coupla guys.
They used to have to send them back to
the step to keep their edge.
Jesus Christ,
you know,
it's like,
because I feel like,
uh,
it's like when I call someone like ally
of people and some New York people,
I call them a indoor cats warehouse
cats.
It's like,
it's,
it's like the difference between a
pigeon and like a bird of paradise with
the big plumes because they don't have
any fucking predators.
Moshe Kasher is a house cat big time.
I love him,
but he's.
Yeah,
he's totally.
same here.
It's like I was with it,
but then we'll get into like all this
shit where I'm like,
it gets all social justice warrior.
Like you don't have any natural
predators around bear son.
Yeah,
he didn't.
You don't hang out with vets as you drop
trees in fucking try to stay off heroin.
I would like to take Moshe Kasher peer
hunting.
That'd be hilarious.
Take him into Alberta.
Let him see a grizzly lock.
Eyes the Grizzly for the first time that
quizzy doesn't give a fuck about
diversity.
It's okay.
Mosha.
That's patriarchy.
Hang a thousand pound thing.
That just needs to eat.
How much does the Grizzly bear needed?
Eta a day.
Again,
let's get the only gays,
but they eat.
A lot of gangs.
Started screaming.
They'll eat.
You will.
Well the stereotype.
Yeah,
that guy was gay.
Oh,
full blonde.
Hundred percent grizzly man.
The number one greatest unintentional
comedy human beings have ever created.
It beats roadhouse.
It beats showgirls.
It beats everything.
That is awesome,
but still sucks at the same guy did I
watched roadhouse at least once a year.
Bad.
I love roadhouse.
Went on a tirade one night on twitter,
I was high as fuck and I was watching
road house and it was just so ridiculous
how gay it was.
Like I like,
how did I miss this?
And so I went on this whole,
uh,
I went on like a,
like a series of twitter posts of Dalton
and what isn't that guy's named Sam,
Sam,
Elliot,
Sam Elliott and Dalton hanging out
together and like,
this is the gay shit.
How did I miss this?
Yeah.
And he never really wanted to get with
that chick.
You always just wanting to be like
shirtless and look cool and like
doorways and shit.
Paint on her.
Yeah.
He just wanted to look tough and cool to
her.
It was amazing.
I know.
And like,
and like it was the worst bouncer in
history,
like you're supposed to deescalate.
And he's like,
oh,
you spill a drink.
I'm a,
I'm going to beat the fuck out of 30
people a bear must eat 90 pounds of food
each day.
Yeah.
If you were telling them to fuck,
they may intake one Ali Wong per day
during the winter.
When food is scarce,
oh my God,
no,
no.
Grizzly bears are specialized to adapt
during warmer months to eat a massive
amounts of food so they can live off
during the body fat during the winter
when food is scarce.
So yeah,
they don't eat during the winter.
Most of the time they just hibernate.
So they get like super,
super fat intake.
Forty kilograms,
90 pounds of food a day.
That's Alli Ninety.
Well you were talking about on a podcast
about a when they blueberries.
It's an interesting flavor.
I never experienced it,
but apparently that's what everybody
says.
And Steven Rinella had a show about it
where he shot a bear on a blueberry
patch and then when he's opening the bar
up.
But you see purple,
like a purple.
Yeah,
it's funny.
My new specials literally called feed
the bear.
I saw that.
Yeah,
that's what she decided to call it that
because like when I get hammered I get
like pretty happy and um,
and sometimes and occasionally on
several occasions I've been like pretty
blacked out and just feed them,
feed the bear,
rather.
It's about like sex with my wife or more
beers or I'm just like,
yeah,
feed the bear here.
Come on.
Feed that bear fruit.
The big old bear.
Good.
Good name for a special as any feed the
bear.
Yeah.
Why not?
Yeah,
I,
I'm horrible at titling Shit.
I'll like,
I'll come up with like 50 and just
having no fucking idea and I just have
to pick something.
Yeah,
they're tough.
It's tough.
Like you be wacky.
DEB self-indulgent degree.
Besides Jamie put on the on air light.
It's bothering me.
The on air light is off.
I feel like there's need to be official.
This new studio.
Watch that.
That's awesome.
Oh see my Dick just moved a little bit.
Mine too.
Nice.
I feel better.
I don't know why I need to see that.
I need to shut it off.
Turn it on when I walk in the room.
Um,
but yeah man bears.
Fuck bears.
Fuck them.
So the reason why we had to build
houses,
I'd be living in tents if there is no
mountain lions and bears and Shit and,
and black bears are.
Everyone says,
oh,
because we have a bunch of black bears,
and they always say,
I like harmless.
They are,
but they're definitely not.
You can still fuck you out.
Kid got killed last year in Alaska.
It during a road race,
race,
a road rage.
The kid was in a road race.
He was 16 years old and he was running
and he called.
His mom,
said that a bear was following him and
then he might be in trouble and the bear
killed him bear.
When the park ranger showed up,
the bear was trying to shoo them away
from his cash because he had buried the
kid,
pulled the kids body into the forest and
was covering up leaves and shit,
and they came and he was defending his
kill.
Yeah,
high stakes shit.
Fuck bears.
Bears.
Bears are not Yogi.
I'm not saying we should eliminate them.
I'm not saying we should kill them all
and make them extinct,
but don't put them above people.
You are God damn crazy person if they.
If you think about your children,
think about your mother.
Think about people that you love that
could easily have been eaten by this
bear and understand that these are these
things or consequence of the natural
world that we engage with and you cannot
put them above people.
It's just you are a trader to your
species.
Yeah,
of course you're missing the whole
lesson that was learned by civilization
and we miss it to the people that the
only thing that civilization is the key
and that fuck the animals,
they miss it too.
But the people that don't understand
what the animals actually are like,
you,
you're missing a giant wolves will eat
your family.
There are a lot of herbivores.
Well,
it's like what you were talking about
with,
uh,
with the people that used to have to
break a rabbit's snack to,
you know,
like my,
uh,
my mom,
my uncle,
my mom's brother there were so poor that
he used to hunt for their food and then
he became wealthy and now he goes to
Africa to hunt,
you know,
the Cape Buffaloes and you know,
and uh,
the Cape Buffalo,
those are really dangerous.
And they call them the black death.
Yeah.
Though I guess they're more dangerous
than like lions and shit.
They can rip you apart thousands of
pounds.
They're enormous animals and they,
you know,
like even lions have a hard time taking
those fucking things out.
There's a,
there's a documentary called relentless
enemies and it's about this one area of
Africa that something happened in the
river shifted course and when the
river's shifted course created an
island,
a very large island,
but on this island was lions and buffalo
and the lions had to get bigger because
all they could kill was the buffalo.
So these lines,
they.
It's a really fascinating thing because
they think it only happened,
man,
I don't want to talk at a school because
I always do,
but I think it was like 200 years ago.
I think it was like a real recent amount
of time and in that time these lines
have developed like hulk,
like bodies.
They look freakish.
The average female lion is as big as the
average male lion on mainland Africa
too.
It's crazy how fast evolution moves.
It's like,
ah,
there's this type of math in England
that was white and it used to hide on
the,
on the Birch,
and then when the industrial revolution
kicked off,
uh,
it made everything city in the,
in the fucking mouth was black and like
30 years because the birds is kept
picking off all the white ones and then
like the only three that were black or
getting all the pussy.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
It's like a,
they say a white person becomes black if
they have to live in African lifestyle
Subsaharan and 20,000
years like you're totally black.
Yeah.
Well that's what white is.
What?
Why does a solar panel for Vitamin d?
Totally.
That's all it is.
Yeah.
We're just fucking snow monkeys.
Everybody is.
Everybody's the same.
We would have been way better off.
We only looked,
we all look the same and the only thing
that separated us were how fucking
stupid you were.
We have been way better off.
That'd be an unbelievable.
We'd be able to categorize people in
like affective ways,
but instead you get these white people
that are only into other white people
like,
Hey,
fuck heads.
It's the least effective categories.
So bad.
It's such a bad category.
Like put dummies versus smarties.
That's a good category.
Credit category.
Same with like,
you know,
I judge people based on like pleated
pants.
Whether you can keep a secret,
keep a secret as massive.
Like keep a secret is huge.
It's huge.
That's why it's like I'll get on boards
or like I'll get on board with some
shit's moving around,
but I don't want to.
I'm not a big reveal guy.
I think that shit's for the birds.
Big reveal guy.
Like when people just talk shit about
people or it's I guess what I.
Now I know I'm not like that distraction
you.
They're like,
if you don't have to do that,
you shouldn't do that.
But the only reason why you want to do
that is we want to create some
excitement outside of what you're
actually doing to progress the.
The life that you live in,
right?
Yeah.
Unless do like calling someone out like
someone committed a crime or something
like that.
We're not talking about that,
but it's like this idea.
I'm just saying I could keep a secret
with a crime too.
If you ever come to the instinct,
the instinct to engage in that is all.
It's all negative.
You know,
and,
and I,
I think it goes back to that whole
reward system thing were I think in a
lot of ways we're very program to not
just accept but even seek out conflict
and to be upset about things and to like
look for those things in the news and
look for those things because we don't.
How often do you see conflict with
humans?
You know,
like if you see like Manhattan,
right?
And you see all these people that are
driving their cars,
walk in,
get on the bus,
get on the train.
The vast majority show no conflict with
each other.
The absolute vast majority.
It's actually amazing.
It's fucking magnificent.
Chimps were so peaceful compared to what
we could be,
but now compare that to the vast
majority of interactions online.
No comparison.
The online might be 50 percent conflict.
Yeah.
And it's absurd.
Conflict.
Yeah.
It's like I'm going to fuck your mouth
with a gun.
I'm like,
I thought we were talking about
healthcare.
Wait a minute.
You can't even do that to someone
explained to you what fuck is.
You can't,
you know the one on the chalkboard if
you fuck my mouth with a gun.
It's like when you reveal that you don't
know something based on an intense.
And so did you see that thing that
someone wrote about Ivanka trump?
All the different words that she uses
wrong and like that she doesn't
understand English.
I mean,
look man,
how old is she?
Like 30.
Oh no,
she's not.
She's not old right now for sure.
For sure.
Don't 36,
36.
I'll give her a pass.
So she is 38.
I just,
you know,
most people don't know how to use words
correctly and then all of a sudden your
fucking dad,
the president.
You're like,
wait,
I thought you were reality show host,
right?
I think I thought it easy road here.
What the fuck?
I thought I would never reached the
public guy.
I'd be fucking flying private jets to
Israel every year if you're like now and
I need to know what magnanimity means.
What?
What about the yacht on the Caribbean?
That's hilarious.
That's what I was preparing my 35 years
for.
All of a sudden after figuring out the
correct use of words did I got a massive
verbal skills and horrible spelling.
I've liked this weird,
like my,
my ability to hear words,
remember words.
My vocabulary is huge,
but I spent like a fucking idiot.
My spelling's atrocious.
Like horrible.
Yeah.
My.
Well,
I rely on that squiggly line,
that red squiggly line.
That's so critical for me.
But what about no suggestions?
I don't play that game man.
That's like,
you know,
like swinging an ax.
Well,
steel toed boots,
but sometimes I don't realize it's in
Spanish.
Oh yeah.
And like as a,
you know,
I'm flying my late night rants and fly.
My thumbs are flying thumbs.
So you do everything 100 percent from
your phone.
Everything from stronger addiction
because you're not even pretending you
might get a productivity done.
Like if you,
if your laptop and you've got Microsoft
Word Open.
Yeah,
and occasionally you check twitter like
bitch,
you don't know shit about Beethoven,
but I'm trying to wind down,
which is crazy because it's like the
worst way to wind down.
It's just like cyber conflict.
That's not a way to wind down.
That's not the way to wine because my
wife would fall asleep before me and
then you know,
I don't want to watch TV and be loud and
sometimes I'll go in other rooms and
shit.
But you know,
well I think,
I mean this is very pretentious to say
but,
but it is true.
But I think that all of us who are
having a chance to talk about our
experiences in this life are influencing
each other.
That includes you.
That includes everybody.
I know the clues red should fear and
Thompson and Duncan were all influencing
each other and we were all in some way
helping each other like mitigate all the
weird influences that we experience.
And there's a big one.
The Big One is our addiction to
information and that the addiction to
information can overwhelm your ability
to process the information.
Like if you're just reading shit about
like world news and a breaking news and
all the craziness you're doing that all
day while you're awake.
Like I say,
if you gave your phone,
like if somebody had a phone and they
had won the mophie packs so they can
keep that bitch run and check the
Internet all day.
At the end of the day,
what have you.
Have you.
Have you even taken the time to
momentarily reflect about what any of
this means or are you just taking a
fucking guy with a truck killed bikers,
you know,
oh wait,
fuck that guy's guy.
Oh,
Dustin Hoffman's a piece of shit to
retweet.
How much time are you spending where
you're thinking about life yourself,
the world around you?
What are the motivations for all this?
Like this kid that ran over these people
in New York,
what's his motivation?
Who is he?
Who did the most awful job ever of
parenting this fucking monster?
Right?
We think that Allah wants him to stomp
on the gas and run over a bunch of dark
[inaudible].
I like,
I was just on that bike path of my son
and I just,
I'm trying to stay objective sometimes
and I'm like,
Eh.
And I'm like,
fuck you.
It's like emotions.
Mac Is Peterson talks about how uh,
the,
the need for information is the same
part of the brain for a foraging food
and now that we have all this food
reforging other shit,
and I think it's like all think that's a
really good point and stressed enough
now that we have all this food,
we're foraging other shit.
Yeah.
We're forging outrage or forging the
need for reform or forging this violent
interaction between cultures were
forging all this fucking craziness
online.
Like every day you're seeing more and
more craziness.
People telling people they can't wear
braids.
People tell people,
tells you.
Appropriation is the most insane
psychotic thing and it's getting worse.
But my twitter timeline think Jamie
Kilstein did us all a giant favor.
I'm not being disingenuous.
I think he did
and I,
and I don't hate that guy.
Look,
I've had,
I've had bad moments by life,
but I've made dumb decisions.
Owning up to those dumb decisions makes
you a real character like someone of of
real character to me.
I want to say I was going to say a real
man,
but it applies to women as well.
Like owning up to those fuck ups is so
goddamn huge and Jamie did it and I
think we need to understand like when
someone does do something like that,
you gotta,
you gotta stand up and fucking golf clap
you gotTa,
you gotTa let people know that and
there's a lot of other people that also
could have these revelations in these
moments that stand up and,
and,
and be real with you.
And then I,
all of us would recognize those moments
and those feelings in our own self and
we can move on better.
We can move on better than we're doing
with Jamie did by coming on this podcast
and talking about his life as a social
justice warrior and all the nuttiness
that he was involved in and all the
rules and regulations,
what you could and couldn't say and how
he knew it and even though he thought
things were wrong,
he couldn't express himself because it
would be outside of the progressive
doctrine that they had to all follow by.
That's giant man.
It's trying for all of us because just
like Jordan Peterson has expressed that
we could all be Nazis if we were that
person insurance circumstance with
those,
you know,
those stresses and pressures.
That's what terrifies us about all this
stuff that you could be that person that
if you were born in Uzbekistan or
wherever the fuck this terrorist was
born,
that ran over these people that have all
the terrible things that happened to
him,
happened to you.
You could be.
That guy was hitting that gas.
Right.
There's no difference between you and me
and Jamie and everybody listening.
We're all just people and we're a
combination of biology where a
combination of life experiences and our
community and our circumstances and what
we've learned that we have to recognize
that instead of like trying to appear to
have moral superiority over everybody
above you because you haven't committed
murder yet or you haven't run a red
light,
were wound up killing someone because
you had an impulsive desire to get to
work on time or you haven't got drove
home drunk because you've made a mistake
and your girlfriend left the party and
you were fucking pissed.
You got in your car and you plowed into
a car.
All those things we want to.
We want to demonize people because we're
scared to death.
Fuck.
Seeing those ideas in ourselves or
seeing those actions and ourselves.
Yeah,
and that and that soldier that's in
line.
The line between good and evil is right
down the middle of a person's heart.
You know,
that we have that.
None of us are just good or bad and we
can't,
uh,
just,
just proclaim someone as bad and as good
unfairly.
Those are the people I root against.
It's not,
it's not the flawed humans that make
mistakes and just our human,
it's the people that demonize everyone
but damn,
and you see that they're almost just,
it's projecting.
It's like the biggest homophobes the gay
guy,
you know,
and,
and that's,
and that's what gets me angry and it's
like when you're trying to get social,
like what happened to me with,
with a defined that kid situation where
it's like,
well,
explain that because most people don't
know what you're talking about.
Most people don't know the
circumstances.
So,
so,
uh,
there is this,
this guy who has a three.
He had a three year old boy did,
he claimed was transgendered and
identified as a girl and started,
you know,
putting dresses on the kid and uh,
treating them like a girl and I was
planning on giving them hormone therapy
so they don't go through puberty and
this dude has like power in Hollywood,
you know,
and um,
and I just called them out and I,
I got swarmed and uh,
I just didn't stop because I'm like,
I'll die on this hill.
It's a hill to die on.
When you were deciding that a three year
old has done developing and
understanding what drives me crazy when
you were talking to is akin to like a
seance will you find out that you were a
roman emperor from 1700,
that fucking three year old barely
understands how to express himself.
The,
the,
the idea that a three year old can give
you a complex definition of their sexual
and gender identity had three and that
this isn't something that you should go
in and chemically influence that kids
sterile,
make them a unit.
Yes.
And it's like,
and it's fucking insane.
It's a projection of the father's ego.
It's not even like is it?
Oh yeah.
The virtue say,
Oh,
it's just a coincidence that it's a San
Francisco like npr guy that like
everyone in Hollywood as his back for
some fucking reason.
Even as a child,
it's like,
uh,
it's just the circumstances.
Explain what,
what.
So this dude,
John Hodgman,
who I thought I was cool with a,
I met him doing a morning radio show and
he was like,
when Mel Brooks set a pc,
shits ruining comedy or something.
All these comedians were like going
against Mel Brooks and I'm like,
wait a minute,
are we the bad guys now?
What comedians though,
Paul have comp time Ken was talking
about.
Yeah.
And I was like,
dude,
you're like the bad guy from footloose
now.
And uh,
and so I'm just being very open about
this because my,
and,
and am I,
it's like there's a few things I'll
stand behind.
Free speech.
Don't fuck the kids,
you know,
don't hurt the kids.
Don't hurt the kids.
Like,
yeah,
just be good to the kids.
You know it because that's you.
That's,
you mean that's what every,
every child is you,
all of us.
I know.
Especially when you're a little tiny
person,
you,
you have this insane responsibility as a
big person when you're dealing with a
little tiny person.
And now that I have a tiny person,
that's what it made me more of a,
a,
a man in an adult.
Like I,
I just felt so much more responsibility
to be good 100 percent on the job too.
He learned on the job like you realize
along the way like,
oh,
I'm like literally dealing with a blank
slate and I can't even process this,
that my fucking bizarre,
ridiculous life of telling jokes.
And in your case,
playing songs with pianos and ridiculous
shit that you say on twitter this
somehow or another qualifies you to
raise a human being so intense.
It's so it.
And also it's like I,
uh,
I,
I've always thought I was a good guy but
not like I ever thought I was like
deserving of anything special,
you know.
But then once you see a kid,
you're like,
he didn't.
He's fucking pure steel a man,
you know,
I'm like,
I've done some shit,
you know?
So that's why I think just as myself
younger,
I wouldn't have been quite as like into,
I've always stuck up for the underdog
and people being abused and shit.
But now I'm like,
I have to be better for like the next
generation because I see him look at me
like humans can be good.
He's like,
Dad,
dad,
you know,
and I'm like,
Holy Fuck that desk a good guy.
You know,
and like I never really knew if I was a
good guy.
Right.
And this is a good experience between
you and him.
He's,
he's enjoying it immensely,
you know,
and it's giant and it's just like he
watches me,
watches me hit my foot with my acts and
as like,
don't do it.
Do you ever think about the fact that,
and this is a conflict that I've
discussed ad nauseum with some of my
friends at every one of my friends that
I know came from fucked up place.
All the people that I'm friends with
Cowan or Joey Diaz or anybody read band
or dunk into their childhood was fucking
chaos already.
Should fear like everybody's childhood
was a mess.
Yeah,
I think it's A.
I think it's to make a good comic.
That's still a good dude.
I think it's a,
it's a combo of like love,
like your grandfather and chaos or else
we're just.
Killers were.
That's the problem,
right?
I think that goddamn comedy and murder
are so closely related.
I know and we're just on the good side.
Killing.
Yeah.
I mean,
that is literally Wiley call it because
my mom listened to our last podcast and
she was like,
I love that you're friends with Joe,
like you guys both have like,
you're kind of fucked up a good guys
where it's like you experienced a
traumatic events and,
and have you experienced damage,
you know,
and then you have paths in life and
you're like,
I'm going to seek the good in this,
but we're still,
you know,
low impulse control comedians.
But still,
you know,
we're not just killers,
what were,
were actually nice people.
But we're,
we're realizing we're nice people in the
middle of all of like a life with a
tremendous amount of momentum,
of chaos behind chaos.
And all the sudden you're like,
whoa,
whoa.
Bracey that.
Okay.
Yeah,
like,
belly,
that beef shit man.
You know,
it's like,
I might as well,
I've had a viking ship for the last 10
years where he'd just viking it up and
it's like,
yeah.
And then you see that the order you need
the cast in order,
you know,
and you see the order with the child and
then you see these people trying to
exploit children.
And I was just awake,
you know,
I'm just like,
you know what?
Fuck you.
I'm like I don't.
And then people in La that I thought
were my friends,
not good friends,
not like comics,
but like middle management.
That's where the evil is.
Well you know what it is man.
It's like the supporting
rights eclipses all the logic involved
in the subtle nuances of human behavior
and sexuality and the idea that a three
year old could have any,
any notion of like what it's going to be
like to be eight or what it's going to
be like to be 16 or whether or not
hormonal changes is going to affect the
way he expresses himself.
So.
And also you're looking at this kid and
you're deciding that this kid,
because there three is going to be
transgender and you want to turn them
into a girl.
What if this kid decides he's a gay man
in five years to kill themselves?
Right,
what it.
Well,
what if they decide that they're
bisexual in 20 years,
you know,
I can't.
If you kill,
if you care about that child,
you don't interfere with that process
because I'm not the same thing that I
was when I was three and you're not
either.
It is so to inject hormones and
chemicals and even surgery that we
really have a very limited understanding
about how much this interaction between
the scalpel and a baby body.
How much of an impact that has you.
You're giving someone the green light is
that they're talking about making this
kid a unit.
Well,
yeah,
they won't go through puberty and so
then it's like they saying,
what are they saying?
They were called the hormone blockers
and I kept asking him directly.
I'm like,
say yes or no.
Are you going to give them hormone
blockers because it's fine.
If he wants to wear a dress,
have some fun playtime fine,
but you're going to tell him he's a
girl,
but here's the thing.
It's not even playtime.
It's like,
what if the kid like feels better when
he wears a dress?
Fine.
Like we're all.
We've all decided that pants and a shirt
is the way to go and if you don't wear
pants and a shirt,
I know you're home.
I'll like if you were sitting there
wearing a big girl skirt,
why did I.
What do I give a fuck?
If you always learned kilt and I'm like,
ah,
I love Scotland.
I wouldn't care.
But if you my brothers to piss out of
each other.
Well,
she said that out loud.
I have a horse thing.
Impulse gave Doug Stanhope pissed on the
fear last week,
a couple of days ago on a podcast.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
pissing happens.
I didn't mean to cut you off.
You were talking about the Scottish.
Who gives a shit.
If you dress like a girl,
what I give a shit as if you step in and
you in any way interfere with the
physical,
sexual,
biological development of a child
because you think it's the right thing
to do progressively that you think is
the right way,
right thing to do.
The right way to approach a fucking
three year old like you are the problem.
There's not this.
We're not talking about one plus one
equals two.
We're talking about a super complex,
very nuanced issue and if there's child
decides when it's x amount years old,
whatever we decide 30,
whatever the fuck we decide to take the
decision to do to get gender
reassignment,
that's a 100 percent cool with me
chorus.
No problem with that,
but that's a person who understands who
they are as a fully developed organism,
not off fucking babies.
Three.
That's a baby dude and part of me it's
like this.
I see myself in the,
in the kid where I'm like,
I played classical piano and knitted
like I used to like knit cloth.
I used to weave,
I went down,
I used to the thing we your piano
teacher?
Yeah.
Like my.
Like my dad is like a.
my parents are married that have a great
marriage,
but it's like almost like a reverse
gender marriage in a way.
Or my dad's like a flamboyant opera
singer,
professor and my mom like six.
One loves sports,
wear sweatpants,
you know,
like my first bit was I was the only guy
in the closet.
I used to be like,
my dad would be like,
let's go see rent again,
son.
And I'm like,
I want to play catch with mom,
you know.
So I played piano since I was a kid.
I,
uh.
What about your piano teacher?
When I was 11,
my piano teacher became a dude and the
bit I tried to work on that,
people don't believe some of the best of
the way.
That's a long time ago.
How old are you now?
Oh,
I'm 37,000.
Ninety one.
That was the.
Oh Gee shit.
Oh,
that's,
gi surgery.
Oh,
that's.
And do my piano teacher right now is
like owens,
totally trans friendly.
Like we're friends.
But I don't think he realizes what's it
become,
you know,
because it's like now it's like,
oh,
you don't believe in making a three year
old a year full of Hay.
Yeah.
This is,
this is not wise because if you just
look at it in,
not in terms of like how a child should
identify,
but in terms of like the biological
process of a developing human being,
it's very,
very touch and go.
We don't really understand what it is.
This is what you should try to do,
what a kid,
you just try to give them nutrients you
should try to give them love and try to
give them safety and try to give them
challenges.
Totally tends to get over,
but.
But the idea that you are going to
decide by your conversation with someone
who just started talking 12 months ago,
they're still shitting themselves.
They don't know how to talk yet.
They shit in their pants,
but they literally don't know how to
talk yet.
I know it's.
I identify.
It's like,
how the fuck does that work?
Do you want to be a girl?
Like my son's dances,
like he's always dancing and shit.
He goes to the piano.
He does with dad.
That does and it's like this kid's
probably trying to impress his dad and
his dad's this fucking asshole.
It's like,
oh,
being trans is brave dad.
And then they're gonna make they're
gonna make moves where the kid can't go
back,
can't go back.
It's life is over you.
You literally turned.
I live down a dark path because here's
the thing,
and this is super unpopular to say,
but the bottom line,
whether you decide to become a
transgender person,
whether you decide to,
you know,
just to suppress those ideas,
it is at this current stage of our
understanding of medical science.
Impossible to actually turn you into a
warm,
of course six x,
y,
so we're going to do is have some
reasonable facsimile and it's going to
be more reasonable in different people.
And some people they have a slender
frame,
you know,
some people have built like David tour
and it's just like,
whoa girl,
okay,
I gotta go like you don't have David
[inaudible] was big time heavyweight
boxer from the nineties
and you've touched on our body
dysmorphia with like weight lifters
where it's like,
you know,
there's certain people that just aren't
comfortable in their own skin and want
to alter it.
Like with like fucking rather that's
bigger boobs or cutting your wiener off
or some shit.
And,
and as a very big personal liberty guy,
I'm all about you doing that.
But you don't make that decision for the
kids.
You don't make the decision for anyone
that's under the age of comprehension.
And here's the thing,
like what is that age?
Because they say that the frontal lobe
doesn't really fully developed until 25.
Asked Geico.
Yeah.
They don't show you.
They want to insure you as a male.
The insurance is up until you're 25
because you're not developing a uh,
I think it's a little earlier.
I think girls develop little earlier.
I now I.
Now I'm fucking pissed.
I'm calling some sort of red pill
organization.
And so long story short,
I make these problematic statements and
then my agent drops me.
And uh,
how does your agent drop you for saying
a three year old shouldn't be given
chemicals that kill his Dick and balls.
That was rocking the boat,
man.
It's a fucking match if you just put it
that way.
So what you are is pro giving kids dick
killing chemicals.
Is that what you are?
Just let me know.
Right?
It's kind of like when it's like words
are violence.
You hold up your fist and you go word or
violence like that.
It immediately cuts through this shit,
but for some reason it's not these days.
Or is there violence?
I mean,
that's a big thing now.
And it's like,
ah,
this college,
Yukon,
drop me,
I'd have like a good gig.
And they said,
because your views,
uh,
we can't,
you can't work here.
And then did they specifically talk
about which views?
Yeah,
I even tweeted the email because I was
sick of this shit man views that trans
kids.
It's only transplants.
That's my whole thing.
But it's trans babies,
dude.
It's taught,
they're toddlers.
They're like three,
dude,
it's,
and I'll die in the hillman.
I even asked my brother,
I like my buddy,
my buddy Mike.
Uh,
Mike,
Mike from a,
a sword and scale.
Like,
dude,
I literally was like,
I'm,
I'm unemployed.
And he had me like read,
uh,
that,
that's when you know,
your friends are mad.
He's like,
Yo,
will you read this?
You can be like a da in this fucking
murder podcast.
I was like,
great.
He's like arthritis from cash.
I thought I was out.
I'm like,
brother,
can I do some more?
Tree work is like $29,
you got boots.
I'm like,
fuck yeah dude.
I was prepared man.
But think about that,
that you as a guy who I've known for a
long time,
it's been a successful professional
comedian or really always that close to
being pushed aside and not given work
anymore over something that's totally
logical.
I just got a development deal,
true TV and shit.
It's not even like I was doing badly.
Did they?
The True TV keep the development deal.
They did not even have reps anymore.
But do you talk to Tru TV?
No,
they're cool people.
I just had,
I've just been so,
like,
so the reps all bend you by saying that
you don't think three year olds?
Well,
yeah.
And trannies.
Yeah.
And also I guess I was,
I was saying it's a process.
It was problematic.
I was uh,
I was,
too many,
too much.
I was just,
I was poking people that aren't allowed
to be poked at this,
these powerful middle managers,
you know,
what were you doing?
Just saying you're wrong dude.
When they're like,
oh,
you poking them about what?
That shit like that's good.
Are we at Man,
can't do that shit.
I don't do he tweets man.
And then the Shaun King Shit where I'm
like making a joke that I think it'd be
hilarious of slavery.
Came back because he'd have to admit
he's white and that's fucking funny man.
I'm not going to back down on humor.
I'm just not.
And then he calls me a white
supremacist.
Actual people with like blue check marks
are like,
I never knew you are racist.
I'm like,
you know,
I'm not man,
it's a joke about him lying about who he
is and uh,
and I'm not going to explain to people
who he is and what that whole story is
because I don't know whether it's true
or not,
but I know what I've seen online and I
know what a lot of Milo exposed but
files Rachel dolezal right now.
I'd be fucking pissed dude.
And it's like,
even if I'm wrong,
let's say he is a black guy with like,
well even if he is,
let's be honest,
like I'm not,
I'm not Irish,
but I'm a quarter Irish.
Right?
But if you look at me,
I look like a Guinea look like an
Italian.
You know why?
Because I'm three quarters Irish or
three quarters Italian.
So fight.
If someone says,
are you Irish?
If I was going on TV,
identifying as Irish man,
right?
What people are infinitely more part.
How much are Irish?
Are you?
I mean people would say that's
disingenuous because no one can tell,
nor does anyone care about the
distinction between Irish and Italian.
You would just a European,
hey,
you are in America.
You know,
third generation,
no big deal.
But there's a reality to that because
like what percentage black do you have
to be where you say,
I'm a black man?
Well,
because he wants the points.
That's why it's not even about pride.
And you don't.
You will,
will,
will.
Here we go.
You don't want is this shit right there?
You don't choose to be trans black.
It chooses you.
This is my life.
My struggle is real.
Hashtag wrong skin.
Yeah.
Is that real?
That's real.
That is essentially it talks about all
the time.
Real tweet from Owen's thing that I was
looking,
okay,
we did some shit that I've been tricked
about so I could create that.
It was a guy,
there was a guy that I was following for
a while that had a parody account and he
was going by Hashtag wrong skin.
He was a comedian and he was always
talking about himself as being trans
racial,
but he was doing it like completely
preposterous and he would be like,
you take like the ultra progressive
really ridiculous approach to like
almost every argument and then always
write like Hashtag wrong skin.
Hilarious.
Because it all started because that dude
poked at me because I had this bit that
I want to be a progressive slave owner
where I'm like,
I'm like,
the reason slavery is wrong is because
it's only black people.
That's not right.
That's racism.
I want all the people.
And I'm like,
if you can't outrun the nuts in the
harpoons.
Yeah,
welcome to the club and that's a joke
about the absurdity of certain
progressive ideals.
And then he poked at me somehow and then
I was like,
this guy's fucking.
Well,
if I can be really honest about that,
I saw fit and I was like,
hmm,
I see your point,
but I think that's like first draft
of an idea of like,
because I bailed on the joke because it
doesn't,
it only works in certain cities,
but this is why.
I mean this is how I felt.
I'm like,
okay,
no,
because I don't want anybody to be
slaves.
Like so like the joke is like it's kind
of cruel in a way.
Like we're not talking about real
people.
Of course,
the sentiment behind it is people who
run slow.
Anybody who can't get away,
she'd be a slave.
No,
no read,
but you don't really feel that way.
You're saying that because you want to
poke people.
Well,
it was extremely.
It was honestly,
of course,
I don't want any slaves.
Of course.
It was always the upside down,
upside down.
Satire.
Weird.
Because that was.
I was.
I know that it wasn't right.
It wasn't quite there.
It was like you,
you were in the neighborhood,
but that's what our job is.
Yes.
That's the whole thing.
It's like everyone thinks that you can,
you start knowing the bit,
you know,
uh,
freedom of speech is all about way
overshooting then pulling back then
fine,
you know,
and I was overshooting like that's what
I do.
Why don't they laugh where it's like,
look at how this one phrase hurts people
and then how you make it not hurt people
based on information I didn't previously
know.
Yeah.
You know,
and it's like,
I'm like,
my wife gave me info about.
I was doing some bit about how vampires
or cultural appropriation for Romanians
and I don't even understand what the
point was,
but it's something to do with Harry
Mexicans,
women.
What is this?
W Jamie woody.
You trying to find it?
He was one in looking for it.
He apparently had hit it or deleted
those tweets.
Now Shaun King is cranking out a
boatload of original tweets in a
continued effort to dilute last week's
Hashtag,
trans black and Hashtag wrong skin
tweets.
Oh,
so you got a bad response to the know
tweeting about that whole thing for
weeks and going on into 2016 and a bunch
of.
You know,
I don't give a fuck man,
if you want to,
I feel the same,
literally the same way as you feeling
that you are a woman or you feeling
anything,
but the real problem is like the
insisting on that definition in a very
specific manner that's disingenuous with
your actual background because everyone
is essentially.
We all came from Africa.
That was the original human beings and
like we said before,
being white is solar panels for vitamin
D.
that's all it is.
It's.
We moved to a place that had a lot of
clouds and it wasn't anything like
Africa and slowly over who knows how
many fucking years people changed and
you develop paler and Paler skin.
That's it.
Yeah,
so it doesn't matter.
I don't care,
but just here's,
here's a better way to do it.
Just act the way you feel like you'd
like to act and don't lie about what
your background is.
Totally.
And you can be the exact same person.
No one will give a fuck.
And the irony is he's trying to get
victim status when he's
not part of a group and because there is
the reason American slavery is so
fucking dark is because it was one of
the only slave systems based on one
race.
And that's why like Carlin did an
unbelievable.
Everything's car like dude Carlin's
covered it.
He has a blitz episode called,
uh,
addicted to bondage.
Dan Carlin.
Yeah.
Dan devcon covered a lot of thought.
You were talking about it did.
I got some of the wolf in May,
but like Dan Carlin addicted to bondage.
We're all related to slaves and slave
owners.
It's like,
it was,
it was actually progressive because of
genocide.
That's the irony.
It's like back in the day and army
winds,
they kill everyone.
And then some Bernie Sanders guy was
like,
let's keep something alive.
And I was like,
you're such a fucking lefty,
you know.
And uh,
and so we grew out of that.
Thank God.
Of course I don't like slavery.
I think I'm,
I'm almost in this position where like,
I'm a little freaked out that some
givens aren't given any more.
Like what?
Like like that Hitler is bad or I don't
like slavery where I'm like,
it's just a given.
It's a given.
Like who the fuck?
Like slavery.
It's like owning a human.
There's still a bunch of retards out
there that think it's a good idea to be
a white nationalist.
Right?
Yeah.
Like Charlottesville,
like when you see that guy got pepper
sprayed,
takes his shirt off,
you see a swastika on his chest like,
okay,
what about the Nazis is awesome to you?
Is it just fucking gassing random
children?
Like,
sit down,
tell me what do you think is awesome?
A bad war plan and Russia,
the idea that are you so fucking stupid
that you really think the only people of
Merit have a genetics that come from a
certain patch of dirt?
Because that was one of the.
That's one of the most toxic ideas.
So toxic man share and it,
it's,
it's toxic in the same way that some of
the left shit is toxic too and they both
have this toxic element where like
unless you look at merit and character,
you're fucked.
Like if you're like,
I'm rather or not,
you think white people are special and
then you should keep them down or boost
them up.
It's both toxic.
I think like when it comes to Rachel
Dolezal like her,
her problem is not that she wants to be
black and she's not.
Her problem is that people give a fuck
about what she wants.
She just didn't have that land.
It just didn't like.
Imagine her whole world could be exactly
the same.
The way she behaves could be exactly the
same.
The way she dresses her actions,
everything.
If she didn't utter a few words that
like I'm actually black and people like,
wait what?
Like,
and then they go into her history.
No,
no,
you,
you want it to be black but you weren't
black.
You look right.
And that just quick,
quick,
quick.
It's just eyeballs.
Shaun king,
I mean he was a part of black lives
matter obviously.
He wanted to do good.
Obviously he wanted to spread good ideas
and help people.
The people that he really identified
with,
if those tweets are real and I don't
know if they are Hashtag [inaudible] and
Hashtag trans racial and all that stuff,
then that's literally how he felt.
He didn't feel it because he hated those
people.
He felt because he identified with them
and they're more attractive to him than
than what he actually was.
So if he just Paul Walden and never
said,
I mean Paul Wall,
right?
The wrapper with the grill.
I mean,
isn't that essentially he's a deep love
of black American culture,
right?
Mean there's a lot of people that just
just be themselves and go in.
Just go in is what I appreciate more.
There's a lot of black people at golf
clubs with fucking Polo shirts on.
Right?
Why?
Because they identify with that culture.
It's appealing to them.
We'll just let people,
fucking cultures,
everything man.
That people.
And the irony is is Joey Diaz,
he's going to get us grills.
You heard about that.
And the irony is is like inner city
black culture,
like things like comes to my shows and
thinks I'm funny because they liked that
crazy shit.
Like man,
you fucking funny,
you free to talk about things.
They just think it's funny.
I,
I think uh,
when I say they,
it's annoying because it's like,
of course not all black people finding
funny,
but like that culture,
that black redneck white liberal culture
where it's like I'm from a culture
that's more similar to American southern
or urban black culture than a lot of the
liberals calling me names and it's just
this type of culture that,
that bonds through shit talking,
you know,
like Boston where it's like if you talk,
if someone's like,
oh,
you're dead,
you're dead x like a home.
I'm like,
well,
is my dad's didn't kill himself,
you know?
And then your friends because it's like
you've hit the darkest shit and then
you're like,
oh,
we'll make it through a winter.
A winter is a big thing to make it
through.
The people in the west coast have like a
way easier,
like the idea of what the possibilities
are.
Then the people that the,
the east coast people in the East Coast
are regularly confronted with potential
death if they're dressed wrong.
Dude,
I live in the adirondack mountains man.
It's like dude.
And that's like class.
Class doesn't exist in my town.
It's you got to fucking shovel.
Yeah.
What time?
Like what time of the year does he get
to where you could die outside timber.
July.
Like by December,
January.
We hit negative 40.
Yeah,
no minus 40 degrees Fahrenheit,
which is exactly the same as 40 degrees
Celsius.
That's where it comes to its clients and
its,
that's where they embrace.
And do we have this tiny town in like w
what do they do?
They get mad.
No,
we build ice palaces and shit.
Do they stock up on firewood in July and
August and September and there's none of
this pc shit.
It's like,
except for one issue I got a little piss
in my town about because like this year
the winter carnival was going to be a
fiesta themed about Hispanics,
but there's like the only Hispanics are
my wife and child,
you know?
And then they're like,
oh no,
we don't want to like be bitch.
Right.
I'm like,
it's not.
Do you know,
I'm like,
we could do a lumberjack theme.
You fucking idiots,
right?
Exactly.
There's no one vikings me.
You could show on Vikings all day long.
All Day long.
Nobody cares.
Big fucking helmet.
You big horns.
Nobody took calls you a cultural
appropriate or if you were like Viking
garb or like a
st patty's Day.
It's a midget looking for a rainbow.
Trying to get gold.
Yeah.
No,
trying to fight everybody.
You can wear green all day on St
Patrick's Day.
What else?
What will this will this umbrella for
me,
it's like he's got an nfl tattoo on his
bicep.
That guy's pretty intense.
Lose that guy.
My new shadow.
Someone would say,
oh,
it was a fan guys.
Jacked guys do it right.
Too fanatical.
He works out all year just for that
fucking scene.
Yeah.
You can be a Minnesota Viking and nobody
gives a shit,
but the Cleveland Indians,
everybody's like,
this is the end of civilization.
I know in Vikings were like worse than
Isis.
Like they would show up and just kill
and fucking bail.
They were the wrong thing to see if you
went to the beach to try to catch some
fish and you saw a boat pull up.
There was no satellite radio back then.
You didn't know what was coming.
If you saw a boat in the distance and
that boat and a dragon head at the front
of it and you're like,
oh fuck.
It's like,
do.
They just wrote a across an ocean and
there were giant,
giant time.
My ancestors probably a little smaller
because it didn't get proper food.
Right.
I got better at giant back then was like
six,
two.
I did breastfeed for awhile.
Those.
The thing about Jack Johnson,
Jack Johnson,
who was the Galveston giant,
that's what they called him,
but you find out Jack Johnson's
Asheville height.
He was the heavyweight champion.
The were the first black heavyweight
boxing champion of the world.
I don't think he was any taller than
six.
Three.
Well,
that's a way better height.
How tall is he?
Six.
One.
Six months.
That's the best male height because six,
seven bloods.
Yeah,
but the Galveston giant.
Think about that.
Think about calling a guy a giant who
only six one,
but in 18,
78 he was a fucking giant.
Yeah.
It's almost like the Middle Ages.
Professors like the guy that can read
one word.
He had three wives.
Even back in the day.
Go,
go,
go back to that.
Please leave that back to the wives.
Where's his wikipedia page?
He just had it.
You go to his whatever it was just if
you just go back,
it showed the three wives.
There it goes.
Okay.
Yeah.
See spouses.
He got tired of given the Deq to Irene
and then he moved out of the lease.
Lucille is,
they're all white ladies by the way.
Get tired given the dicta her moved on
to Eta.
Gave the Dick to her.
He's like an ll cool j song.
Bam.
That's crazy.
I was looking for overlap.
Hold on,
go back please.
Jamie's just a click and feet.
He loves clicking.
Look at that.
I'm the last one is I read was last one.
I guess 1946.
Didn't what?
How did he die?
He died in some strange way,
but uh,
he was only 200 pounds to.
There was a giant back then.
Imagine that.
That's so intense.
Yeah.
That's nuts.
I mean,
you've got to be like 2:40,
right?
How much you want to 50?
I'm like,
I'm like 15.
Over two because the beers and the
fires.
Beers and fires everyday.
Shit Buddy.
Fire doesn't put weight on you.
I know it'd be a drink the beers and it
also makes me cook a lot at meet with
like fucked up sauces.
What does it say?
Does it say his death?
It was a really interesting thing
because it's pretty widely believed that
he took a dive when he lost the title
and then he was just tired of getting
arrested constantly and harassed and he
just wanted out.
He was sick.
A crushing sick of white people,
you know,
he's banging a little white chicks.
That was the heat.
That was some heat back then to it that
I could get you killed.
That was way before [inaudible] dot com.
Like we didn't have your bag.
Him.
What is.
He died in a car crash on US highway one
near Franklin,
North Carolina.
Wow.
After racing,
angrily from a diner that refused to
serve him.
Pissed dude.
He's like the opera closest black
hospital sake.
St Agnes Hospital in Raleigh and he was
68 years of,
uh,
of age at the time of his death.
He was buried near at a WHO's,
I guess his last woman has grave,
was initially unmarked,
but a stone that bears on named Johnson
now stands above the plots of check at a
Anne Irene.
Wow,
that's dark man.
It's really crazy.
I mean,
that guy was just born in the wrong
fucking time.
That was bain man.
That guy was born in darkness.
Like imagine being black in the fucking
early 20th century.
Like Holy Shit.
And he just rose champion.
He became the champion and a,
an interesting style.
If you watch the way he fought,
he fought different if different than
other people.
What did he do?
Well,
he just had,
he just had a long reach and had really
good power for the time and he was just
very smart.
He knew what a drag guys that deep water
and beat the fuck out of him,
but he fought like a murderous puncher
who's a middleweight champion named
Stanley Ketchel.
It's a fascinating fight because Stanley
Ketchel only weighed like 160 pounds,
this tiny little dude,
but it was just a little savage.
Stanley Catcho,
Jack Johnson on the Chin and fucking
dropped him and it was like a big deal
at the time because everybody wanted a
white guy to beat the heavyweight title
holder and the White Guy was way
smaller.
Like,
look how small catchall is.
I mean,
he's fucking way smaller than Jack
Johnson.
But Jack Johnson overestimated him.
And Stanley catcho caught him with a
murderous righthand.
Stanley Catcho was a savage.
He was the middleweight champion of the
world.
Ideas at him.
Sorry this says,
Tom Burns to like Mike Tyson's punch
out,
beat the shit out of Tommy Burns.
Go see if you can fight any.
Slowly tortured him and beat him up.
See Find Stanley Ketchel.
Stanley Catcho was the guy who was the
middleweight champion.
And uh,
it was a really interesting thing
because Jack Johnson seems like it's
taking it easy with them for a little
bit and then capital catches him with a
bomb.
Oh,
is that it?
This is like,
look,
they had like warmup stuff.
They were warming up and they showed
them training,
like how they would train back then.
It's really interesting.
Nobody knew what the fuck do.
I'll just run through the streets and
shit.
I shouldn't be run.
That's awesome.
They're just trying to figure it out.
You know that Stanley catchall way
smaller.
Just waste more than Jack Johnson.
Johnson might've been 30 pounds heavier
than him.
Maybe even more.
Do you think like a mighty mouse could
take that dude right now?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
No,
he wouldn't.
Not Boxing.
But in mma you would never hit him.
He wears.
I mean,
unless you figured out some way to stop
him from moving and him in.
He's so fast.
He would anticipate your movement and he
would just slowly dragged these fucking
guys to the ground.
He's like,
Neil,
for Matrix.
It's like I started watching a bunch of
clips based on your indoor,
like talking about,
you were talking about how he's like
pound for pound.
Just the craziest fighter ever.
So my best.
It's not the craziest because he
doesn't,
he doesn't fight crazy.
Fight Smart,
you know,
see if he could find were canceled,
drops them because it's a big deal
because nobody expected it.
I think this is already will catch us
getting fucked up.
You see his face.
Oh look at that.
He got jacked just back it up.
Just a hair so we can watch that again.
This is a back of the time.
This is a giant deal because Stanley
Catcho was a white guy and they were
like,
finally we got a black guy down on the
ground and it wasn't even a big white
guy that did it,
you know,
and everybody wanted Jack,
Jack Dempsey to come back
there still there.
We're still in denial at the point that
like black people.
That's a serious right hand now.
I think Jack Dempsey actually was after
this.
Now that I'm thinking about that,
I'm like,
I'm wrong.
They wanted Jim Jefferies,
I think no clue.
Was it that they want he beat?
Who did he beat towards the end of his
title reign man,
my boxing histories.
Terrible dude.
After he got knocked down,
it was almost like he was like,
ah,
fuck this.
And he just,
he just went crazy and just took them
out.
Literally it was going down before you
got hit.
I was weird.
So that again,
it might have been that he got caught
with his legs tied up.
Watch this step on the foot.
Nope.
Hmm.
One more time.
Please watch your step forward.
He.
Yeah,
he was almost like going down because he
knew the power of the punch.
He definitely got clipped though as well
as also ducking his head and got clipped
on the way down,
but he was ducking way down where he
might've fallen down or at least fallen
off balance even if you didn't get hit,
but who is this?
Who's the main do that?
He went back and forth with go to the
web to is wikipedia.
James Jeffreys may think it is James
Jeffreys.
Yeah,
but at the time when this was going on
to have a black heavyweight champion,
I mean,
I don't think we can even fathom the
level of racism this guy experience
unreal.
I mean literally every day worrying for
his life.
Meanwhile throwing hot dick at white
chicks,
but it's almost like the gang kind of
thing where it's like that environment
of just darkness made him such a fucking
diamond.
J Neil still lived 20 years old and
Ralphie may as I bought her man,
I was a good dude.
He wasn't good dude.
What?
I mean,
think about the life of a person that
lived back then.
He made it 68,
died in a car crash because he was mad
that a bleachers wouldn't serve him.
That's cool.
That's good way to go out though.
I guess it's not the worst way.
It's quick.
It's better than being hung by some
racist for sure.
I do.
Being hung with suck.
That sucks.
If you're going to be executed well,
what do you pick?
Are we really doing this kind of stuff?
What do you want to talk to them guys?
Come on,
try and do bits.
Guy Hangs people.
Um,
what's the worst now?
How would you want to go out?
Like let's say you're actually are your
sentences daddy quick.
You want a quick bullets are quick
bullets for sure.
I used to say lethal injection,
but that shit's all bullets.
If someone knows what they're doing,
you know,
you get someone to shoot you.
That actually knows how to shoot people.
What if you just get hit in the deck and
they understand that?
That's a bad way to Dan to end like that
catcher?
Yeah.
Just get hit right in the deck.
Like the head of the Dec.
Not even like the ball is just no more.
Dick.
How loNg is it going to be before if you
got shot in the foot and your foot blows
off,
they could take you to a lab and they
grow you a new foot.
I think it's soon.
I feel like it's soon.
I feel like it's within 20 years.
I feel like within 20 years they're
going to be like,
if you,
if your hand got mashed and some sort of
advice,
they're going to be able to give you a
new hand.
I think it might even be sooner.
It might be,
but I'm given to 20 years,
so I look smart when it comes.
True.
Yeah.
like you called it you were like,
yeah,
I feel like in 20 years and be like,
you called it for.
I'm more.
I'm all about brains where it's like,
I just don't want to go crazy.
Yeah.
Well they,
well not only that,
we want to be able to repair people that
have been injured,
like car accidents.
Yeah.
Do you know the story of sam kinison?
About how.
Yeah.
Go tell the story though.
He,
he was one way as a child and then his
mom says that he got hit by a car and
then after that he was wild.
Just crazy.
I mean he really got hit,
like to the point of,
you know,
they were worrieD he's going to live.
He survived and he became a fucking
maniac.
And tHis was talking about you with
tomatoes he got on twitter and just lost
his representation.
No,
but I think that,
I think that about myself a lot of times
because I got hit in the head a lot when
I was young and I'm like,
well,
how much does that affect me?
Affect my rational thinking?
How much does it affect my ability to
control my impulses?
You know,
like,
um,
I was,
I'm on a flight once with michael irvin
and michael irvin who's a really good
guy,
was talking to me about kids who grow up
in terrible environments in that these
kids,
if they're in the room,
the womb and their mother
is experiencing violence or stress or
domestic violence or you know,
she sees crazy shit that those impulses
go through her body and they directly
affect the way the fetus develops.
And the children who grow up with
violence around them,
like literally they're conceived and
they have,
they develop inside the womb of a mother
is experiencing all that.
They have a higher propensity for
violence,
a shorter fuse.
They're more worried about things going
badly and it was more intense.
More quick to pull the trigger and that
all of that is a direct response,
like a biological support system,
like your body's trying to keep you
alive and that the more you encounter
that sort of reinforces that.
The more times you get hit,
the more times things hit you,
the more times you get hurt,
the more times you know you crash heads
as a football player,
you get punched in the face as a boxer.
The more times a tomato hits your
fucking dome at 90 miles an hour by some
kid who thinks it's funny,
but whatever it is,
like what?
Whatever things that are rattling your
skull,
those things reinforce your brain's idea
that violence can come at any moment and
you have to be prepared and that's that.
That quick alive.
It's the scorpion and the frog.
Shit.
It's like your nature keeps you alive
and that quick trigger I think
translates to various aspects of your
life,
not just to things where there's a real
situation you have to deal with.
Like,
you know,
you have to be able to react quickly
because your body is programmed to be.
Oh,
I get hit a lot.
I'm ready.
When things come to me,
I'm going to fucking fight him off.
I'm gonna fight them.
I'm ready for somebody.
Talked some shit on twitter.
I'm going to say something,
kevin shit to you,
you fucking piece of shit.
I'm gonna.
Say something that's going to allow me
to call myself a white nigger.
I'm reading,
like I said at first drives drive crazy
verbal nuclear weapon on people.
It's like I knew a lot of girls that
were like a sexually abused kids.
His kids,
it became promiscuous because they're
like,
I'm going to fuck you before he fucked
me.
You know what I mean?
Like,
that's,
that's common.
Well,
there is that,
but I think there's also something that
happens with people that were sexually
abused as kids where they become
hypersexual as they get older.
For sure.
It's not,
it's not good.
I mean,
we're not looking at this in a positive
way,
but I think course activity where we're
talking about when it comes to,
um,
through a history,
human beings molesting children,
that it was insanely common and it
probably wasn't until like what,
what year?
So people realize that it's a horrible
thing to do.
Was it like the 18 hundreds?
It's just one dude's like this is crazy
because did they did the same thing with
violence?
Like infantry comes from infant,
like they would send the infantry was
always like 12 year olds.
What tree comes from Infants for cannon
fodder man.
They used to just send out the kids to
get fucked up.
Really?
Yeah,
like right now in africa.
Glad these,
like little militias like the kids is
when you get the sociopath because if
you don't raise them right,
they'll fucking kill anybody.
God damn.
Oh dude.
It makes me so because I like,
my town was riddled with like pedophile
priests and shit and so it had a real
bad situation with riddled because we
had a mon senior,
there was messed up.
I'm long dead shit so it doesn't matter.
But like he would bring in other ones
and then they were just.
Do you think he talked about it?
Yeah,
for sure.
What do you think that I said I can't
even imagine man lays there.
I bet it was some kind of code and just
kid pushes back.
Dude.
I was always an I.
I never,
I never think they talk like girls like
guys talk about girls like guys talk
about girls like girls.
She loves coke and she's down to fuck.
Like do you think they literally talked
about abusing kids the same way a man
would talk about or a woman even?
We talked about hooking up with a guy
he's got a big deck is going to be
awesome.
You talked about It like in an openly
sexual way.
I can't,
I,
I don't.
I don't even know fuck.
Like it's just like is there some.
Did they use that code but it like it
crippled.
My town is full of like there's some
weird shit going on there with that.
Like not the town I live in now,
but the other like where I'm from,
great people love where I'm from,
a lot of pride where I'm from great
town,
but like there's some shit going down,
you know,
crazy that you'd be in this great area
and just one element makes the whole
thing chaos.
Just raw and everybody accepts that
element because in some perverted way
you really think all that kid fucking is
connected to god through it.
And It always was the kid with no dad
and shit.
That's why I'm fucking,
I have this hyper like,
like you were talking about that
response shit.
That's mine where I'm like,
if you're going after vulnerable people,
it makes me insane.
well that was the sandusky thing,
right?
Like he would always go after kids that
didn't have a family and he would help
them and he created all these
organization,
this organization rather to uh,
you know,
like a charity organization.
Yeah.
To help these young kids and he's just
do it.
And that's why I get furious about the
people that misrepresent themselves a
lot more than the.
Like there's all these scandals in
hollywood now and,
and you know,
the spaces in the weinsteins of the
world are so much more dark and evil
than like,
you know,
there's that scan with andy dick and I
like andy dick.
I'm like the dudes and obvious dick
robber and he feels bad about it and he
fucking just wants to get punched.
When they asked him what did he,
what was his initial,
what was his initial comment?
Was something like a kissing and licking
his.
What he does,
he's been doing it for something like
that.
No,
ma misbehaviors.
His middle name or misconduct
misconduct.
They're signing up for something.
yeah.
Yeah.
That,
you know,
they were upset because they fired him
from an indie film because of sexual
misconduct.
By the way,
I hate to be cynical because I don't
want to say that anybody who wasn't
victimized,
but if I was running an indie film that
was so fucking stupid,
I hired andy dick.
I might be the type of guy that would
make a statement about andy being andy,
just like we're going to put our foot
down.
he enough capital and you ever have
enough and then,
hey,
if you want to see this film,
it's going to be appearing at the sunset
plaza and blah,
blah,
blah.
It's a good move.
At least gets people talking about
something that they would never have
talked about because andy dick hops into
the river of speculation as to who's a
molester.
Yeah.
But like for me,
he's so much law,
like he's just,
he's not going to make.
Yeah.
It's not like the snake in the grass
where you like,
oh,
that guy's misrepresenting himself,
don't cosby.
Exactly.
It's,
it's a dude is like,
oh,
I grabbed the deck and got knocked out.
He's always just like a deep rabbit.
He tried to grab my dick.
I knocked them down and then he
apologized and I was like,
you're all good man.
I know that you're just freaked out.
You get excited about weans man.
And rita was like,
oh,
thanks for not really fucking up any
dag.
And I'm like,
he's vulnerable.
it's vulnerability,
dude.
It's like some people are just these
vulnerable people and like I'm a giant,
like he's not trying to.
It's not about power,
he just blacks out and grabs winners,
but he's also like in a different way
than you.
He's a perpetual button pusher but it's
not necessarily like the worst thing in
the world to be that button pusher.
But that is what he is.
He's not,
he's not as competent with it as you.
He doesn't navigate the waters grabbing
dick's,
andy's,
but like,
you know,
there's hills and valleys to like your
interactions with people and like
there's certain hills where you like,
you go,
you could just get way too crazy with
it.
You bring it down and he tried to figure
out what's,
what's a good middle ground?
Andy just,
it's all spikes.
It's all like ah,
the ground and that's what I have a hard
time judging people.
Like the pr person I've always been is
trying to not be judgemental.
It's the,
it's the snakes that I'm like,
oh you're,
you're telling everyone about global
warming in your private jet.
Like you can go fuck himself,
you know?
And it's like,
it's the same with like andy,
I'm like,
andy has never acted like not a train
wreck dick grabber.
And lIke when my friend died,
the dude wrote me a fucking sweet email.
Like he's a sweet man.
He just blacks out,
tries to grab wieners,
gets sober,
no more winter grabs.
And so when I see them getting pulled to
the mock,
I'm like,
you can't associate him with these like
power fucked up guys that are like,
you want to watch me whack off on a
ficus?
But here's the thing,
like the park guy,
can zack I ever make it back now because
no one's for them anyway.
You know,
It's,
it's not like a iron man.
it's like,
yeah,
that dude,
he used to do a lot of fucking drugs,
but we're still rooting for him because
he's vulnerable.
You know?
It's like no one's.
No one relates to the guy whacking off
on a fucking plant in front of gwyneth
paltrow.
You're like,
bro,
you're out,
man.
You're out.
You're out of the tribe.
That's why the dude didn't.
You just Interviewed a kill scene or
whatever.
Like he has a way in,
he has a way back in because everyone
relates to reward it.
He's not like actually raping.
People just got mixed up and like,
like likes on twitter
and shit,
but this is the idea that I want to
explore because I think it's
fascinating.
is there a point where a guy fucks up
too many times?
Like say if harvey weinstein jerked off
into one plant.
One time he was on coke,
he got crazy and he's hanging out with
someone.
She's like one of the naked vampires and
dusk till dawn,
but she doesn't get to talk to snake on
her and she's so hot and he's so fat and
so gross and he's so coked up and so
drunk and he also has a billion dollars
in the bank and he started saying,
well,
I can put you in a fucking movie.
I can put you in.
If I could give him benefit of the
doubt.
I'm like,
that guy loves photosynthesis.
He loves it.
Like,
dude,
get synthesis.
He's whacking on a plant.
He's like,
yeah,
you take fucking carbon.
You know what photosynthesis is
convicting can changing sunlight,
sunlight into food.
RIght now we're talking about whacking
on a plant,
but that's not photosynthesis in the
plant making shit.
Yeah.
But photosynthesis is like the specific
process of,
uh,
of,
of a plant converting sunlight into
energy.
No emphasis.
I have no impulse control.
Let's find out what that is because I
could easily be wrong,
but I thought that photosynthesis meant
converting.
Turning light.
Light.
Yeah.
That's sugar,
right?
Just not come.
so turned out bro.
He's like,
look aT you making sugar out of sight.
Oh,
I get it.
okaY.
So he got excited by the photosynthesis.
See,
that's the thing is now people are
starting to treat me like I'm this like
moral high ground guy and I don't wait,
hold on.
Who is doing that because of the fucking
standing up for three year oLds.
And I'm like,
dude,
I wouldn't judge one plant whack.
I'm not as the difference between the,
you know,
like transgender three year olds and
some coked up studio executive course.
Here's the thing,
I don't want to excuse anybody's
behavior that's done anything to
victimize other people,
but it is a fascinating aspect of
hollywood culture that forever,
if you wanted to get a part,
you had to go to the casting couch and
everybody knew it and there was a lot of
those guys that had disproportionate
relationships like they were disgusting.
He's disgusting and his wife is fucking
smoking.
Ever seen harvey's wife.
She's smoking and no need to bring her
into this at all,
but I'm just explaining like this is a
consistently disproportionate
relationship that exists throughout
hollywood.
Like there's the guy who was insanely
wealthy but physically vial and he
somehow or another managed to dunk his
dick and attends before he coaxed
himself into an early grave.
That is a fucking common common common
theme.
Yeah,
and I'm not judging that guy who's just
getting tans when he's a two.
That's the american dream.
How would you do it though?
Exactly?
It's about hating limit.
It's about it is about him,
but thIs is my point.
It's like you do not get to dunk your
dick intends unless you do all the
things that that guy did.
He produce shakespeare in love.
That's a dictum.
I'm not.
I'm not excusing him.
I'm not exonerating him and I'm like,
women do not naturally feel attracted to
obese guys with bad skin.
It isn't.
This is not a common thing.
like in order for him to force the
outcome that he desires,
he has to cross cultural inappropriate
boundaries.
You know like this is just like we're
dealing with like mathematics or
literally,
and I'm not exonerating him.
Again,
I can't believe I have to say this,
but I don't want anybody taking this out
of context.
If you are dealing with this as a
system,
as a biological system,
like say if you're looking at it from
afar and you had no connection to
culture,
no connection of civilization,
you'd be like,
well,
what is this?
How does this system working?
Like how is this one like extremely
flawed biological entity oozing its way
into these perfect shapes?
A good finds,
a way to penetrate these perfect shapes
with thin waist and perfect asses and
beautiful faces and his face is just
this pile of slava numbness and just
discussed and is growing hair on top of
it and a little fat dick and just shoots
incompetent sperm into the mouths of
tens.
LIke what?
What?
What is happening here?
What's happening here is there's no way
he would've been able to do it any other
way.
It's like so like he's not thor,
right?
He's not a,
he's not some fucking Ryan Reynolds type
character with perfect cheekbones.
He's just like blah.
And he's just feeding that back with
coke and fucking booze and blow jobs
and,
and constantly trying to put out more
things that allow us to buy the biggest
fucking house,
the highest sales.
And I mean this is literally the only
way he can do that.
We can do that as to be disgusting.
Like girls aren't just going to line up.
I loved,
I loved your movies and I'm just like,
do it to me what you want.
You'll get one out of a million that do
that,
but that's not enough like they have to.
They would have to find him through the
crowd.
That's not gonna work.
It's not going to work.
It's almost like that crazy mindset,
and again,
not exonerating,
not excusing,
but that mindset of like,
look,
what is the mindset of someone who wants
to run the fastest race?
What is the mindset of someone who wants
to make the fastest jet bike zero to 100
time we fucking hanging onto these
handlebars.
What is the mindset of that?
I don't know,
but it seems to be some sort of bizarre
croissant,
competitive biological environment where
people are chasing some strange,
unattainable,
highest ground,
right?
Yeah.
It always comes from a,
like a slight flaw,
lIke the sand makes the pearl.
The calla comedians are little flood.
Like somebody come at it and I like.
They were talking shit,
but I was like,
you're so right to go,
dude.
Owen is the tallest do with the napoleon
complex I've ever seen,
and I was like,
you're fucking right man.
It's like ambition comes from this weird
like feeling of threat where you're like
at any moment I like,
I gotta try,
I gotta work really
hard.
I was trying to work on this bit but it
just never went anywhere about like um,
civilizations based on cock size where
you got the japanese and the english
took over the whole world because
they're,
their chick is like we need more,
you know,
your dick.
No good.
and then like sub saharan africans have
these monster hammers and their chicks
like you're not taking over shit.
You got that big old caulk and they just
stay put exactly where it's almost like
ambition sometimes can come from
insecurity,
which I am riddled with and a lot of
ambitious people are totally.
Which is the point that I was making is
like you have to be disgusting to want
to chase down,
tail to the point where you're willing
to rape as like at that level.
Right.
And it's like,
and I think like that guy gets a billion
dollars and he realizes chick still
don't want to fuck him.
And he spirals.
Why don't think it matters.
I think he's constantlY caught up in the
pursuit of doing it,
you know,
and I think probably it was like super
exciting to get the young starlet who
like didn't know any better,
didn't,
you know,
wasn't really 100 percent sure she was
gonna make it in hollywood and having
that threat of like controlling her
career over her,
like a giant vampire.
And then that Was the horrific nature of
it for those women.
That's what's getting people
particularly angry about this.
Not that he was a fat gross guy trying
to get laid.
Like we've seen those throughout the,
throughout human history has always been
people trying to get laid,
but is that he was doing it in a way
that was victimized.
Exactly.
Costing psychic scars.
Yeah.
Because like what does this,
brett ratner,
same stuff today?
Well now it's just getting crazy.
It's just like,
it's going to be like kermit the frog.
It's under control,
but it's like a,
like I'm the opposite.
I need like a ton of consent.
Like I'm like,
it's like,
oh,
I like your dick six,
but,
but you don't love the dick.
Have you ever seen people like there's
been people that have said that you
should have a consent form and that you
should videotape the signing of the
consent form?
I was watching this youtube thing with
this guy was talking about consent forms
and like that you should get people to
sign a consent form and like what
Michael Jordan does that shit.
I think if you're like a billionaire
maybe,
but like that's fucked up.
That takes away the whole thing.
Well it's definitely a different thing.
It's like what a consent form.
It's like a merger and acquisition of
two companies like your dick,
dick ink and pussy corp was like,
are you cool with this?
And you gotta sign that shit.
Well,
I mean you're seeing things where people
didn't feel cool about it many years
later,
but in the moment maybe they just let it
happen and then you decide that that
letting it happen was way worse.
You know?
Then they were thinking about it at the
time and then decided some sort of a
sexual assault and then it spirals
onward and outward.
It's like,
you know,
it would be really nice if people were
just attracted to each other.
I know,
but like,
it's like someone pasted some of these
people though when they're talking about
like eye contact being some shit.
Like I had a friend like this is,
this is dark,
but whatever.
Uh,
there was um,
you know,
she was kidnapped and like gang raped
and nothing.
Yeah,
dude,
it's like there's so false or
like stupid accusations that like,
it clogs up the system to the point
where I'm like,
you know,
I wanted to just kill these people,
you know?
And like the wolf is getting in me,
the wolf will,
that the boost urban.
I'm talking about how I want to kill
people.
Standard on this podcast goes up once
every couple weeks.
But uh,
yeah,
it made me really a fear infrastructure.
Like where I'm like,
oh,
the cops come with a pencil.
It's not that csi shit.
And it's like there's peace,
there's people out there that
legitimately hurt women and I,
I want them to die.
And it's like,
you know,
there's a nine month wait,
I'm like a rape kit because fucking some
chick regretted some shit when she was
like texting and coming over with
condoms,
you know,
I'm like,
we got to start triaging some of this
shit,
you know?
Well,
you gotta we have to be very,
very strict on both sides of what we
tolerate,
you know,
and we,
we,
we cannot tolerate real rape.
But we also cannot tolerate false
accusations to 100 percent.
Cannot tolerate indulgences where people
have distorted perceptions of reality
and they paint what they know somewhere
at least subconsciously to be some very
inaccurate interpretation of the events,
of course.
And we also can't,
can we,
we can't condone the cosby type shit
that went on for years.
We can't condone rape.
We can't condone people who drug people
or abuse people.
We can't condone that shit.
Don't either.
One of those things.
But I think more importantly is there's
something going on right now where
there's a hypercharged environment where
people are terrified of being called out
and people are like waiting,
like looking around like what's gonna
happen next?
And then people are thinking about some
shit that happened to him a long time
ago.
Well,
you know what?
This has been fucking sitting in my craw
for 18 years.
Dustin hoffman.
It's time.
The world knows and not like hard boiled
eggs.
Dustin,
I don't know what's true and I don't
know what's not true.
I do not know.
I cannot comment and no one can,
but it's this.
There's something that's going on where
this I would hope and I.
This is what I always hope.
I always hope that any wave that goes
this way eventually goes that way.
And I hope that any outrage leads to
more understanding.
Yeah man,
all of this stuff and all of this,
especially this fucking rape shit,
that I feel like there's more rape talk
today and more understanding of how many
girls get approached or fucked with or
harassed or even actually raped or
drugged than we ever thought before
that.
I'm hoping this conversation leads to
more understanding early on in people's
lives before they formed this idea of
what is and isn't acceptable.
Yeah.
Because that's a good thing from it is
it is making people be like,
you can't treat women this way,
especially
young kids here at early for sure,
but hear it when you're young so that
you don't ever grow up in some sort of
an environment where the people around
you tell you it's okay that it's us
versus them and fuck those bitches.
Whoa.
There's a lot of people grow up with
that.
I know and it's like,
you want to be so good that women want
to fuck you.
That's what makes civilization grows.
It's the.
It's the move.
Dude.
You know what?
I can say beethoven by ear.
You think it wasn't for someone to take.
I had a great penis.
No,
I'm just kidding.
I started when I was three.
I didn't know what I was doing.
You did somehow knew that you were a
male identified as a piano player.
I always say be the man that you pretend
to be when you're trying to get laid.
That's awesome.
Just be that guy.
We can all do that.
And by the way,
if you weren't that guy two weeks ago
and someone keeps sticking to your face,
it doesn't mean you're not that guy now.
Alright,
relax.
Everybody relaxed with the finger
pointing.
Like if some dude make some sort of a
terrible mistake,
goes off the rails a month ago or
whatever it is,
just it doesn't mean that he's not.
He's,
he's an ineffective process.
He's a trial and error process and you
can't judge someone tiredly by the
errors,
forgiveness and growth.
It's also like you gotta,
you gotta,
judge the whole thing as a big picture.
You can't say,
you know,
in 2001 arnold schwartzenegger pulled
out his dick and a sauna.
Yeah.
AnD he was jacked up.
He's trying to beat some people in
weightlifting that was probably trying
to have a psychological and intimidates.
I went to.
I made love to hook this.
You want to touch the deq word goal
happen.
You think you can clean and press.
You think you can fit this in your
mouth.
You're less of a man.
And the woman is a woman.
And another thing is we can't keep
calling men like toxic because men,
good men keep these fucking shitty
rapist men beaten down.
Somebody put this on a fucking poll the
other day and they Sent it to me.
Somebody put,
they saw a photo of it or they saw an
image of it and they send it to me.
Whether they tooK it themselves.
It said,
eliminate masculinity.
Ah,
listen,
when the vikings come and do that,
good a need.
Men in the most masculine guys I know
are the least likely to fucking rape
anybody.
They're the ones that defend women.
Well,
there's a few women are attracted to.
Yeah,
there's,
there's some dark law.
And you know what?
Here's the thing about a lot of those
dark people,
the dark,
like the color.
I mean he meant pigment john.
I didn't,
I didn't.
The dark mindset,
the,
the predatorY rapist mindset.
There's a ton of those people that come
directly from trauma that come from
being violated themselves.
TheY come from being in bad situations.
They come from being programmed
incorrectly and exempt.
Again.
I'm not exonerating them.
I'm not excusing them.
I'm just thinking that it would do us
all a world of good if we could look at
these people from afar.
I didn't experience that.
I didn't grow up in a familY filled with
crime.
I didn't grow up in a family filled with
violence and murder and,
and,
and I did a neighborhood filled with
people robbing people left and right.
I didn't grow up with thAt.
So my looking at it as a complete third
party outsider.
but I'm thinking I try
to pretend to imagine what it was like
to grow up in watts in the 19 sixties.
Yeah.
Try to pretend what it was like to be
incompetent in the nineties.
TrY to pretend.
Well this is where I think transcends
that is still cruelty because like all
hang with legit gang members and feel
safe when you're hanging with cameras.
Well I'll do like cleveland and bravo
and then afterwards I'm smokinG blondes
with like dudes that I,
you know,
have leveland improv has gang members
waiting for some fucking people.
Man.
It's like,
you know,
someone's wearing a bulls hat and a city
without red or like someone's got
teardrop tattoos and like I don't feel
scared because I don't like if they have
a body count,
it's because of threats and business.
It's not like cruelty and I think that
there's even in like fucked up
environments,
you still have the cruel man and the
good man,
even if they like do things that you
don't agree with in your social economic
area.
THat's the hero's journey,
right?
The strong person that's kind enough to
take care of the people that are weak.
That's what the,
what everybody wants,
right?
As someone who is a strong person that
looks out for the week person,
which is why everybody like the term
bully,
which I think it's overused,
like sometimes bullying gets used when
people are equals in.
When someone is critiquing someone,
oh,
you're a bully.
I go,
listen,
I just think that's stupid.
That doesn't make me a bullet.
You're using it wrong.
This is not.
We're not talking about children.
We're not talking about people that are
physically weaker than me.
Like let's,
let's be clear about what the fuck we
mean when we say this very polarizing
word,
but that word is polarizing because we
absolutely don't want to be the person
that's in the position of physical,
moral,
ethical,
economic,
whatever it is,
superiority who has influence over the
other person's life and steps in and
fucks with it.
yeah,
that's what it.
That's what a bully is.
Spine,
okay.
With passion can be like,
fuck these people and people are like,
okay,
even if you're a little off the mark,
you're not trying to hurt people to make
yourself feel better for your own
inadequacies.
That's what's evil.
Or if you are,
you need to understand that that's what
you're doing,
right?
because we're all equal.
We're all evil and good.
Just make the move.
But also just to have someone like
pointed out makes you go,
am I like and think about it?
You,
you're not necessarily your words and
your actions,
which you are as how you've dealt with
your past words and actions and make
corrections.
I mean,
that's,
that's really what you are.
I mean that's.
And that's what's really important
because if we don't give people that
leeway,
they don't ever learn from their
mistakes.
mistakes than we were essentially
committing to a future with no one
learning anything.
Right?
Yeah.
And it's like I gave on dave smith and
steven crowder both this a compliment.
It's like,
because even if you disagree with
someone,
the thing I love about people is like if
you make a good point,
they look excited and happy versus
threatened.
Even if you're not on the path that I'm
on,
you're still trying to like carve your
fucking sculpture with it to look
beautiful and not a threatening posture.
Yeah.
And that has nothing to do with the left
or the right.
I mean it's really Just how you approach
information.
Yeah.
To all 100 percent.
Because I think a lot of times people
from the right do not want to accept
good ideas from the left and vice verse.
I think that's just a,
that's a real issue that people have.
And that's a weakness too.
It is a weakness and I've experienced it
from my own mind and I'm sure you have
from yours,
bro.
You've seen my twitter.
Everybody has.
It's important that we realize like
what,
what is that reaction that we had and
how do we,
how do we mitigate the negative aspects
of it and how do we figure out how we
got to that point where we said
something maybe we didn't believe or we,
we,
you know,
we reacted to something in a way where
if given time to reconsider our,
you know,
the potential going this way with it are
that way with it,
we'd probably come up with a better idea
and a cool thing you do for men,
especially men,
because I could speak on behalf of men
because I identify with the winter and
balls.
Thank you.
It's like you,
you,
you make people think about their
actions where it's like,
but I think about mine,
think about yours too,
which is why we gravitate to each other
100 percent where it's like,
is this good?
Is this,
is this productive for me,
my family society?
Like what exactly am I doing right now?
And it's like,
and with my recent shit,
like some people are like,
oh,
how's your wife feel about your spiral?
I'm like,
spiral.
she's never wanted to fuck me more.
Do you tribute your twitter numbers?
Keep going up to I know my where's the
spiral?
I know and I'm like,
oh,
I'm representing a group of people that
they keep writing me emails.
Like thank you so much for not calling
me just evil for my,
like what I,
you know,
my basic beliefs because I'm not
supporting racist,
sexist,
bigoted,
homophobe kay kay kay,
you know,
it's fucking crazy dude.
And it's like,
and I'm not going to fall in that trap
either.
where I'm like,
oh,
I'm jewish grandmother,
my wife's hispanic,
my piano teacher's fucking trans.
It's like,
no,
my idea is strong and I don't need to
justify it with my association with
people that you fucking could have
justified it.
And with good reason like it really
does.
It is a trump card.
When you say,
look,
my dad's probably gay.
Hey,
look,
my dad wears outfits that are
questionable,
but he's a loving man.
Hey,
look,
my my piano teacher used to be a dude,
a woman as a woman.
Now dude.
Yeah,
I became aware of same thing.
It's all good.
it's all there.
Like,
like hispanic and crane.
Spanish like home depot,
mexican.
Yeah.
Anybody,
anybody that calls you a white
supremacist like,
okay,
I see what you're trying to do and it is
so transparent that it minimizes
everything you're ever going to say ever
from this point on,
on this subject,
because I always have to think,
well,
you're intentions are disingenuous.
Well,
you're trying to do is divert people
from tHe actual reality.
so this shaun king guy,
maybe he's a really good guy.
He's just a white guy,
is a dickhead.
Well he's a white guy.
Maybe he's a good guy.
It could be an albino nigerian.
I don't think he's that and I don't
think so either.
It looks just like his dad and his
brother.
Maybe he's a really good guy and this is
just.
He hangs out with the wrong people and
as the wrong ideas in his
head and he's followed the wrong
operating system to a in a logical
perspective where the only way to
disagree with is to call you a guy
married to a home depot mexican or white
supremacist.
It's okay.
I know you love your wife joe.
Of course.
I know like she doesn't work at home
depot.
She works at lowe's.
I know.
Listen,
I've known you for a long time.
You're the opposite of a racist.
You're just not.
Yeah.
It's so fucked up.
Like right now in 2070.
It's like if you're truly not,
you sound almost racist because you're
like,
you're like,
if I'm going to make fun of the why's,
that make it fun.
Everybody knowing that.
Like if you stand up and say,
hey,
you can't just openly make fun of all
white people,
that's fucking racist.
Too stupid to do.
I'm going to talk about,
you know,
your employment record.
Dude.
I saw this lady's tweets and I did not
retweet it.
I thought about retweet and I'm like,
I should fucking turn some fire on this
bitch.
Bitch,
well thAt's what I'm for it.
no doubt.
Turn up the heat.
Well,
okay.
I don't want to do.
I don't want to be the guys dms get
discovered and finds out up and secretly
plotting against radical feminists,
but this lady wrote,
she wrote all white cisgendered.
If you don't know what cis gender it is,
it's not real,
but with heterosexual men who are
actually heterosexual today is the way
to marginalize normal people.
That's another mcdonald's.
All white cis gendered men are shit
unless proven otherwise.
Okay honey,
you might be a cut cut and I know you
don't want to be a con,
but you probably like,
I don't.
Maybe it's the geometry of your nasal
passage to cheekbone,
to chin structure.
Maybe you got crooked teeth,
maybe you're on athletic and guys don't
want to fuck you.
Maybe you've dealt with all the wrong
guy.
maybe a perfect genetics.
Maybe your brain is accelerated.
Maybe you look at me like I'm stupid ape
that I am.
I don't know what the answer is,
but you can't say that now have no
repercussions for your actions.
You can't say all white straight men who
identify as men are shit until proven
otherwise because that is crazy.
Was racist,
sexist,
racist,
homophobic,
and it's stupid because if that was the
case,
if we were all shit,
it would be a damn rape festival in the
streets of every major city all over the
world.
If you really thought that we were all
bad,
let me tell you what all bad looks like.
All bad looks like the world filled with
coked up vikings just running through
this tree mouth.
Fucking everybody you've ever met.
That's what men can do,
and I'm not bragging,
but that's what if you're.
If you,
if you have lingerie on and you can
close your eyes and walk through a
football field in front of a large
crowd,
one of them cheerleaders for like
football and no one just tackles you and
starts fucking you in front of when that
is,
because most people don't want that to
happen.
That's why.
Well,
I'm convinced that's why they keep
coming at like white american dudes
because we were some of the most chill
guys name,
but we've done some know.
There's some fucked up shit,
but they're,
they're coming at us for a reason and I
want to say us now,
we don't have a rape culture though.
We,
we,
we see a rapist.
We go fuck that guy,
but there is a lot of rape,
but the problem is uNtil now there
wasn't enough of an ability to express
what written and on both sides,
like some people call things raped.
That's like,
wait a minute window.
You were both drunk and it was
consensual,
but It's rain say ruin.
A dude's life falls for.
That's happened and I had fattiest
russell on.
He was talking about the incident
occidental college where a man and a
woman it technically,
they're both lIke over 18.
They di,
they got drunk,
they decided to have sex.
the girl called,
the guy texted him,
you have condoms.
The whole deal.
They agreed to get together and after
the fact the girls friends decided that
it was sexual assault because she was
intoxicated,
not even taking into account.
They were both intoxicated,
right?
Both agreed and there was text messages
back and forth.
Remorse does not equal rape.
Having a bad experience.
Percent.
yeah.
Both for the guy and the girl.
I mean it's just like people fuck up and
they make mistakes so you get it.
You got to figure out what is and what
isn't.
And with thaddeus was talking about was
that the girl went back to school with
no repercussions,
but the boy was sober.
Life is over cross.
there were two people who are attracted
to each other who were exchanging text
messages,
who were influenced by the ideals and
the,
the ideology of all the people around
them do it and how the media just like
hits trump so hard that sometimes I'm
like back off so I can mock them a
little where it's like.
Because I have that instinct of like,
dude,
I can't market guy.
Everyone's fucking unfairly calling
shit.
he's not.
But it's like,
look at this guy who in occidental
college,
I don't remember his name,
but look at this kid and then compare
them to bill cosby.
Exactly,
dude.
Exactly.
Real snakes.
Let's call real rapist.
Real rapist and call an 18 year old kid
who was drunk or I don't know how old he
is,
maybe he's 20 and a 20 year old gIrl
who's drunk.
Call them kids,
call them kids who it's not like this
guy drugged her and duct taped her.
Like let's,
let's look at what it really.
Is it really just two kids that got
intoxicated and had intercourse with
each other and then one of them felt
bad.
god damn.
How many times do you feel bad about
sex?
Because a lot.
Because It's almost like that,
that,
that thing of like the leprechaun,
like he got caught the leprechaun.
It's like an old parable.
It's real short.
I'm not going to drag on a parable,
but like elaborate guy got caught and
he's like,
yeah,
I'll give you the treasure.
It's under the tree with a ribbon on it.
So he put the ribbon on all the trees.
So now the ribbon doesn't mean shit.
So everything's rape.
Rape isn't rape.
It's like if everything is racist,
racism isn't racism.
And you're like,
you're now taking away our ability to
identify predators and it's a dude's
like us.
It's like,
I promise ladies,
I promise you,
if,
if a guy breaks about rape will fuck
that dude.
It's like no one likes that guy.
You're in a small enough community where
people feel responsibility.
That's the big problem.
I read about this once.
This is a phrase called diffusion of
responsibility that happens in a large
group of people that see something
happen.
Like there was a picture it genevieve,
where she got killed in front of 40
people in New York city.
Exactly,
exactly.
There was a picture of video rather from
chicago.
Really recently.
See if you can find jamie.
We're a guy assaults a woman and he did
it on a security camera.
He had kicked her and knocked her out.
I mean it was fucking awful.
I don't know what led to it,
but this guy punched her.
And then I mean like still skillfully
head kicked her.
Like he took martial arts before.
It's kod.
She falls down and a bunch of people
walk over and start filming her.
She's as.
So this is one that I,
I don't think I retweeted because I
think I'm not,
I'm not entirely sure if I remember
correctly,
but I think I thought about retweet and
I'm like,
look,
people don't need to see this.
This is not something I want to promote.
And support was someone wrote,
this is like an episode of black mirror
because this guy kicked this girl and
instead of calling nine one one,
these people are filming this girl while
she's curled up in a.
Did you find it this,
it's.
I don't even know if I want you to find
it this,
but this girl curls up into a fetal
position on the sidewalk and they're
standing around her filming it.
Well,
I think,
I think a big political divide isn't
good evil,
blah blah blah.
It's population density.
It's like cities like what we're talking
about,
all these monkeys going by each other.
No one's eating each other's faces.
You want a powerful government to keep
it chill.
But if you live in a place with a 40
minute police response time,
it's about individuality.
And that's when he started going more
libertarian because it's like,
well I have a gun in chickens,
you know,
versus like a big city where it's like,
we need a powerful government to keep
everyone relaxed.
You know,
you can't always rely on daddy,
daddy,
all dude.
I've seen what happened.
Fucking daddy doesn't do shit.
Daddy's a guy.
Wanted a job being daddy.
Yeah,
that's what police daddy is,
please.
Daddy is.
I mean sometimes you get great guys and
sometimes you get fooled.
It's like across the board.
Like you might run into the best guy
ever when you're shopping at walgreens
and you might run into a fucking moron.
You know?
And exactly man.
It's like a job needed to be filled.
And you might've hit the perfect guy.
And I love the way you describe govs.
It's like it's the hardest job in the
world,
the hardest,
the hardest soldier.
And then you,
you,
you meet cops are like,
god bless you man.
You're the greatest.
And anemia cops capture.
I'm like,
oh,
you wanted power.
Fuck you man.
And it's like,
it's,
it's such a hard job.
it's like teacher,
you know,
it's like all my family are teachers and
it's like,
oh,
these are like,
throw away a job and it's going to be a
teacher.
It's like,
oh,
you're going to educate the youth and
cops are going to keep us safe.
Those are our fucking warrior heroes.
You know it.
You know what I mean?
THis is a very
easy thing for me to say when I say I
haven't had a bad experience with cops
because I haven't,
I really haven't.
I mean I've had cops get mouthy with me
before,
but I've always said,
no sir,
thank you very much.
So I've always been like,
I've always like immediately try to
diffuse the situation,
but I'm a white guy.
I,
you know,
I speak pretty calmly.
I am a comedian,
I'm an entertainer.
A lot of them know me from the ufc at
this point.
It's almost like I'm out of the game
right this point.
Like cops run into me,
like almost all cops are fans of the
ufc.
So if I run into a cop,
the cops like,
oh joe rogan,
hey,
what's up man?
I'm like,
hey,
what's up man?
And he realized like,
oh,
this is a guy,
I'm not a terrorist.
Like I'm not,
I'm not a criminal.
I'm out of the,
the,
the confusion.
Like he doesn't have to worry about me
shooting him in the head.
Oh totally.
And shake his hand.
I'm like,
what's up brother?
How you doing?
Every.
And they were all good.
So I'm almost looking at it like a
privileged outsider,
but even when I was young,
because,
you know,
my actual biological dad was a cop.
I don't know him,
I never knew him,
knew him until I was like six got great
genes and umbro but that.
But I,
when I was a kid I remember thinking
like,
what a crazy job like he has to go out
and that is fear,
fear,
fear.
It's also probably one of the reasons
why that led him to be so fucked up,
you know?
And I never really like let him off the
hook for that.
But I saw a lot of dark shit from my
actual biological dad when I was a
little kid,
like violent stuff.
And I was like,
well,
of course he's lit.
He's a cop in New Jersey in 1967.
Like how do you,
how do you not be fucking violent?
Like,
totally,
you're not going to live.
You're not going to survive.
You're,
you're on the front line.
And then going from that to a martial
arts,
from the time I was 15 years old,
I was completely immersed in martial
arts and I ran into a ton of cops and
they were all like regular guys.
And it made me think like,
okay,
this.
When I think of a cop,
I don't think of someone that I'm
running into the trying to lock me up.
I think at some poor guy who has this
position in life where he's the guy who
has to put the badge on and hold the gun
and wear the stupid hat and stand in
front of the criminal and go put your
hands up.
I hope he doesn't get shot by a guy
behind him that he doesn't know exists.
And this is his life.
Twenty four slash seven all day long
comes home to his kids their sleep and
he kisses him on the head and he thinks
about the kid that he saw shot in the
apartment building in the bronx to it is
to think about that stuff.
It's like I'm boy with a lot of cops
where I live and a lot of them are
troopers who were really well trained
and they're like the coolest dudes ever.
And they just,
it's almost like the cops emotion is
just like where it's like you just
microwave your fucking baby dude.
Yeah.
You know,
where it's like they see this shit and
then like I do a benefits for like a
tour de force and shit for like fallen
officers and because I have so much
compassion for that shit,
man.
It's like they are the watchdogs of our
area.
But then you get the bad seed or you get
someone who makes her horrific mistake
and justice isn't
given and that's why it's complicated.
And you know,
sometimes it's about like lawsuits where
it's like,
you know,
someone fucks up and no one wants to
admit they're wrong.
And then the community that witnessed
that,
it's like they want their,
like they would just want justice,
but let's also,
the punishment of fucking up is so
extreme.
Oh my god.
Imagine if we bomb and we fucking
gilligan back.
You know,
it's like one of our jokes bombs and
someone fucking kid dies.
Oh,
that's why dude,
cops deserve a lot of respect to do it.
It's like it's a crazy job.
It's a crazy job and you're dealing with
pressure that most of us could never
possibly imagine.
And the life and death decisions that
happen at the blink of an eye and you
are responsible for those decisions for
the rest of your life.
And this is something that I talk about
too much.
I got to piss so bad.
Jamie,
can you keep a conversation with owen
benjamin?
I'm a lightweight.
I don't know how to hold mY pee anymore.
Bareback and malcolm gladwell's blink,
blink book.
Hold onto that thought.
I will.
Hey jamie.
What's going down?
What's going on,
man?
Man,
he's about to pee out of his car and I
first time he's had to do this during a
podcast.
I think so.
Rocktober fucked him up.
Yeah.
He never has to piss.
Never.
It's a three and a half hours or we're
two and a half hours in to.
I think this one's going to go for
awhile.
Yeah,
I was going to get you guys some more
ice if you needed it.
So I fucking love rogan,
man.
He's such a good dude.
What are you looking at?
I had a couple of things pulled up to
talk to you guys about talking to me
about anything man.
Uh,
we were talking about south park before
this.
Two of the greatest show ever made.
What's,
what was goIng on?
And you said the halloween episode just
happen.
Yeah,
it's about.
No,
It's a,
you got to see the new south park.
the,
the dudes drink jack and smoke crack.
That's not a,
that's not a spoiler.
It's the first act of the episode,
but definitely check it out.
I just think that sometimes people ask
me where I,
where I land politically and I usually
just tell them south park because it's
like,
it's just as objective as you can
probably get to the point where trey
parker is like a fucking genius.
Awesome.
Such a big fan.
I wish he would come talk to us here one
time.
Um,
I got tripped.
Tripped parker if you're listening,
you did hire me once.
A comic con in san diego.
I don't know if you remember that.
Uh,
to host a thing.
So why don't you coMe on the rogan
podcast?
Yeah.
They just had the new video game came
out.
I don't know if I was trying to explain
that to you that you were talkIng about
that,
about taking not taking shit.
The game's called fractured,
but whole.
Not butthole but the word,
but in the w,
h o l e o butthole.
Exactly.
Play on.
It's profound,
but you have to take a shit.
And everybody's house all over the city
to be mark making your mark
did.
The thing I love about south park is
that they go after everybody and that's
why I have so Much respect for them,
you know,
they tried to go after islam as much as
they want to after the mormons and
that's why I'm lIke,
you guys are great,
you know,
because it's all about just like no one
gets a pass because that's when you
create martyrs and shit.
You know?
I like doing podcasts way better,
high and stoned and drunk too.
This is fun.
Way more fun.
Sober october is important.
You know why just like running up a hill
is important because it makes you
appreciate naps,
dude,
in ways as I miss my weight fast.
Yeah.
You got to do chin ups,
weight vests if you important.
Champs more than pull ups a day.
They're both the same to me.
I just need pulling exercises.
I mean there's a bunch of different
ones.
I actually have these things where the
handle's rotate so we'll watch different
ways,
but it's just a matter of lifting your
body weight.
I think,
uh,
when I talked about movement before,
it's one of the things that I got from
this whole month of doing yoga and I
knew I've been doing yoga pretty,
um,
pretty extensively or this guy's a
switching back and forth.
That's a good move.
That tough.
I to ask you about that.
Yeah,
it's hard to do.
it's hard.
It's hard to release.
It's because you're essentially throwing
yourself up and then exploding to catch
yourself.
I wonder if he whacks off like that.
He says,
why not?
Why wouldn't you just keep switching?
What I learned from the yoga thing
though,
and I've learned over the last few
years,
is like,
it's a balance issue.
Like what yoga does is balance
everything out,
not just balanced in terms of your
ability to stand on one foot,
but also balance the difference between
the strength of your major muscle groups
and then your tendons and your back and
your core and the connecting things like
your knees and your hips and all these
things that you never taken into
consideration.
Like you don't really put a lot of
emphasis on when you do other things.
But when you do yoga,
you realize,
oh,
my feet are giving out first,
huh?
Oh,
like my hips are getting sore when I get
into triangle pose,
like,
oh my,
you know,
and all that different stuff that you do
that I'm like,
it leads to like the strength and the
strengthening of uh,
ignored aspects of the entire system
and it also keeps you off your phone.
Like I've been doing hot yoga with my
wife and it's like,
it's so hard and she's so good at it and
like it's so funny because she'll do,
we'll do hot yoga together like once a
week,
maybe twice a week and she'll get real
horny and I'm getting real dehydrated.
So it's like that.
It's the most frustrating combination
because it's like she gets really in
touch with her body and she's so fucking
hot and it's like awesome.
But then I'm like,
oh,
I need about a gallon of water to make
my cock.
Like,
awesome.
Well just drink that gallon of water.
I work on it.
But I usually,
I usually under bring water into the hot
air.
The key to the the yoga is you got to
drink the water beforehand.
I'm usually hung over from the fucking
pbrs.
Yeah,
you gotta drink,
especially the hot yoga.
You gotta drink.
Try to drink like a leader,
like a leader of water,
like maybe an hour before and even more.
I tried to drink.
What is 64 ounces.
How much does that have happened ago?
Ounces to leaders.
It's all confusing.
God,
I wish we would switch over to the
metric system.
It's way better than english fucking
king.
That just screwed it for everybody.
Yeah,
I did it
with his foot,
but we tried it again in the United
States and I want to say the seventies
or the eighties?
Two point seven liters per day.
Hold on.
Ninety one out.
Sixty four ounces of water per day.
Recommended we consume 91 ounces.
Okay,
so two point seven liters is 91 ounces,
so 64 liters is probably somewhere in
the neighborhood of two leaders.
Oh yeah.
One point eight.
One point eight,
nine liters.
I think that's.
That's what I bring to yoga.
I bring a 64 ounce thing.
I think you can get that in the before
class,
like if you could get up early and drink
water with lemon in it,
you'll have a better performance because
there's literally like,
like an.
I see it a lot from guys that get
dehydrated and try to make weight.
You're,
you're literally dealing with the
electrical signals that go to your
muscles are not going to fire and brain
and brain.
Yeah.
Like I got a camel pack and I crush it.
Why mowing my lawn?
Do you like a water bladder and with a
straw?
Yeah,
I love it.
because they usually when I cross
country skiing,
because if I pull my hand out of my
glove,
my hand freezes that.
Those are great for hiking too.
Yeah.
And hot.
If you're at a hot or cold weather at
high climates,
at high altitudes,
I'll get dehydrated shit.
Like an aspen at the aspen comedy
festival back in the day that day I'd
have like three beers and be like,
I'm king of the world.
I did a show with lewis black and they
had oxygen backstage for us.
Really?
I was like,
louis,
what the fuck is the oxygen for?
I guess if one of us goes to horror,
they slapped that fucking mask on your
face.
I was like,
that's crazy to training up there.
That's like where the olympics train and
shit sometimes.
Yeah,
because it's like a fucking dime for it.
Anytime you can get it high altitude,
it's just they,
they say you should actually work out at
low altitude but lived most of your life
at high altitude.
I'm at like 3000.
That's good.
Thousands.
Definitely better than zero,
you know?
And um,
if you can get accustomed to that,
they say,
I talked to a dude once when I lived in
boulder and he told me that it takes
three years for you to fully acclimate
to a high altitude,
but that once you do fully acclimate
those like extreme,
like cardiovascular benefits,
well,
but you get a sweet boner.
Maybe not,
maybe that's the trade off.
You're going to run forever,
but your dick is always recorded mast.
That's what I miss about la is the beach
runs and then the people like dudes like
you and like just really brilliantly
creative people and also the beach runs
and shit.
It's the physical beauty ir.
I don't miss that entertainment industry
and the traffic was a different kind of
beauty.
Right?
like you're in the mountains.
It's so gorgeous.
But I missed those.
Like the oxygen's zero fucking feet
above sea level just running.
I,
we used to live in marina del rey and
that path I just listened to dan carlin
just listen about fucking genghis khan
is I just run with my fucking camel pack
and that was a blast.
That's,
that's the thing about la that I think
is really beautiful.
It's like the amount of biomes like
mountain,
you know,
there's some desert.
This I'm a beach or ocean.
Yeah.
I think you're right.
But I think um,
you know,
if you have the ability to travel to all
of them,
you'll.
Well I think you appreciated probably
where you moved when you first moved
there.
Right?
Yeah.
And I still love it though,
man.
Like now I'm like,
I'm,
I always miss it when I'm,
when I'm away from it,
but I know what you're saying.
Yeah,
it's easy,
right?
It's easy to get like real accustomed to
what you see right in front of your
face.
Yeah.
And like I have so many memories now
with my family there and my chicken just
giving me food everyday.
They just keep shooting out eggs and
wolves up there either.
Right?
We got coyotes and I've learned a lot
about guide.
Who's from your podcast?
Dan flores.
Do you kill them?
They,
they multiple,
either like gremlins.
You can't kill coyotes.
So actually the worst thing you can do.
Well,
the things spread their range to me.
Uh,
there's a type of cat phisher fisher's
fisher cats to keep jacking my shit.
And uh,
foxes and raccoons are my enemies.
Coyote is not so much.
Coyotes will get a chicken if they can,
but coyotes are smart.
There are oddly clever,
like they figured out how to avoid
people.
You know,
one of the things that I found most
fascinating about dan flores book,
iod America was the mythology that the
native americans had about coyotes,
that the coyote who was essentially a
god and the kid was a god that was
watching over you,
like watching what you did all the time,
constantly judging you and try.
It was really weird.
Like the native american and some
tribes,
their interpretation of what a coyote
was,
it was really fast.
I mean,
they're pretty powerful if like if they
jack your chickens,
like sometimes like we were talking
about empathy,
like what's it like to live a different
life?
I'm like,
what if I needed these chickens?
Like I got more chickens but we had one
chicken holocaust and I'm like,
we're fucked now.
Imagine if that was like the winter and
like the chickens are gone.
It's like what do we eat?
But here's the thing,
you weren't fucked.
But the coyote is like,
this is.
I had a weird come to jesus moment when
it came to coyotes when a coyote stole
one of my chickens and I watched her
talking about a tricky trick.
My dog called is a honeybee.
Does Johnny Cash?
Johnny cash is my mass mast if and
Johnny Cash is a tank.
This is how fucked up Johnny Cash Johnny
Cash got into the chicken coop just like
honey.
A couple of months ago,
just a couple of months ago,
Johnny Cash tore through the chicken
wire with his paws and got in and it was
a chicken holocaust in there.
Killed.
Who's eating them?
Yeah,
he killed like four chickens in one
setting.
It was a disaster and I saw him in my
underwear.
I went outside.
I was like looked out the window and I
looked.
I saw the fuck and I ran downstairs in
my underwear,
yanked him out of the chicken coop.
I pick them up and throw him outside.
He's fucking 12.
He's an old man.
Good for him.
But he's still getting after it.
Just getting that.
Did you do like name your chickens and
get bumbling?
Well,
I don't but my wife fucking clunky and
fucking meredith and shit.
Prince's petunia princess between you
got jacked by Johnny Cash a little fyi.
Dubai what names?
Like deer and shit,
like one spot.
And I'm like,
I think my brother wants to kill spot
dude.
Fuck,
spot up.
Don't do that.
You know?
But that's,
that's the thing.
It's like I,
if they were in my neighborhood I would,
I would,
I would probably name them too,
but I'm on the road a lot and that's
what I know she misses me when she's
like,
oh here comes david.
I'm like the raccoon,
raccoon.
It's always just a fucking animal spot.
Might have to go.
David might ask to go yet because my
brother's getting into hunting now and
like I think he wants to kill spot.
So you have taught you,
you talked about it before,
the podcast that you thought about
actually getting into hunting yourself,
but you don't want to wound down.
It has to be a quick kill because I
would love to hunt and,
and my wife wants me to hide because uh,
because my uncle hunts a lot and
whenever we stay with him he's always
got like pheasant and shit and like it
gets me pretty jacked up like natural
animals.
I think there is some juice in it.
It's like there's something different.
There's something going on.
Does anybody around you hunt and is
willing to take you?
And literally everybody didn't want to
mentor you.
Fuck yeah.
All you have to do is learn how to shoot
a rifle.
Right?
And here's the mean,
there's a lot you could read about
shooting,
um,
but you,
you have to get someone who sets up the
scope correctly,
sets up the rifle correctly,
and then you just have to.
Someone have someone teach you the
proper form and how to just only move
your finger.
Just pull,
pull,
pull and get a surprise shot.
You can't go.
You try to shoot because you'll flinch.
And the,
a minor movement left or right over 100
yards could equal.
It can be the difference between a
lethal shot and shooting an animal in
the butt and anybody who's shot a rifle
including me has done that before.
It's not good.
And we shoot a lot,
you know like oh well we have will shoot
like ar air fifteens and shit.
Like in the we'll,
we'll get a nice section of land.
Like my brother has 40 acres in this
beautiful area and it's like.
And by the way,
it's so cheap up there,
dude.
You can get an acre for like 800 bucks,
you know,
and you just get this,
this,
you can wait.
You can get an acre of land for 800
bucks and it's the most beautiful shit
you've ever seen.
Is it a direct flights?
There's a,
there's a airport and fucking sarah,
I'm not going name.
You have to fly like you have to fly
like syracuse or some shit and then take
a puddle jumper that killed somebody.
Some lethal.
There's some weeds.
Flights like body holidays.
There's enough,
there's enough like super wealthy people
there that we have like a pretty legit
airport and this little area because
it's a.
But they fly their own jets in those
fuckers.
They do,
they fly their private jets into your
little funky town and then they just sit
there and then we are always like,
well,
you pay us to hunt for you.
But dude,
you do like it up there.
My brother's like,
dude wants to hunt because it's like,
how many animals do you have up there?
What kind of animals?
We have moose,
deer.
It's probably hard to get a moose tag
though right now.
It's not that hard.
It's hard to miss.
Yeah,
they're talking about shooting a house.
They're like an ancient logan animal
man.
It's so crazy looking and they're
fucking vicious.
Oh,
well they do.
They are rare in the deer family.
Like all deer will fuck you up if they
have to.
Especially when they're in rut.
They're just like,
yeah,
but a moose will try to fuck you up.
There's a difference because they're
constantly dealing with grizzly bears
and brown bears and they can fuck you
up.
They can.
Their big dude.
I saw him once up there and it was like.
It was like a come to jesus moment.
I'm like,
oh,
I'm not,
I'm a guest in this area.
Dude.
I shot one that was young.
He was like,
he had like a little fork on the left
and the fork in the right and each one
of his legs was over 100 pounds.
I had a scoop his leg up and throw it
over my shoulder bigger than alwan.
It's almost like a stone in england
where it's like how many ali wongs way.
There's a.
I did a cover for peterson's hunting
magazine and on the cover I'm holding a
moose leg over my shoulder and it's a
crazy picture.
Like you look at how big that fucking
leg is and that's not a big moose.
The moose that I shot was only like
maybe 900 pounds.
It was fairly small for a moose,
but that's like the entire offensive
line of the dallas cowboys.
Yeah,
right there.
That's awesome.
That moose would've fucked me up.
Like there's not a way in hell you could
have stopped.
That moves from stomping a hole in your
chest.
Yeah,
and they want to.
It's like a lot of prey animals get is
almost as vicious as the predators.
Uh,
even though I don't feel as much empathy
for the prior,
so like if I wounded a fucking cat,
yeah,
it'd be like,
you learn your lesson brow.
Like my,
my brother recently hit A raccoon with a
pitchfork and lived.
And uh,
I didn't feel bad at all.
Well he lived as far as you know.
Yeah,
he's definitely dead now.
But that's happens.
come in the henhouse definitely had some
like leakage.
Yeah.
That was the man that was the weinsteins
coming in and trying to get our hands.
we fucking stabbed his ass.
No,
he was more ethical.
Like what he's doing,
he's just trying to eat.
He just found a way to eat and we starve
and he's in that hardscrabble life of
the wilderness and there's,
there's a lot of food up there.
Like it's a beautiful area.
There's no supermarkets for raccoons now
they just got to do.
They have a whole foods recommends up
there.
So a lot of chemo for raccoons.
Keen was young.
Soy isolate.
I love pea protein.
Does this,
does that.
Give you boobs too much soy.
You you would know that shit.
It's like I'm extraordinary amounts.
I think it's one of those things where
people like really over exaggerate the
impact of it to emphasize the femininity
of going vegan.
Right.
Her.
I don't think it really makes you a
woman,
but I think that,
you know guys like,
hey,
and you could just eat bison duke good
harder.
You start planting flowers.
So lactating.
Yeah.
You start speed walking to bisons.
Good shit.
They were almost gone.
Does soi really caused man boobs?
Let's find out where on a website is
it's fitness.
It's just never trust doctors with dr.
Name now.
Dr stacy.
Legit.
He's legit.
He's a friend of mine who's on sirius
satellite radio.
I got to get him on,
man.
He's supposed to be on a million times.
We never.
We never put it together.
Dr steve.
Let's make it happen.
That you're steve mann.
Dr steve focuses on very bizarre
venereal diseases.
He talks about them in depth.
You're like,
wait,
what?
Huh?
like syphilis.
you can die from that.
Like is there ones we don't know about?
Not yet,
but for sure they're coming.
It sounds like there was no herpes and
all of a sudden there was herpes and
that's it.
That's why I like being married.
It's like I don't have to worry about
that shit now.
So think you don't.
What about toilet seats?
That's.
That's a good point.
What about sneezing and I like to whack
off on toilet seats.
What about what if plants fight back
like a fucking shama lama.
Ding dong that shit.
That's what I'm saying.
Like what if they fight back?
We whack off on him and weinstein.
Imagine if,
if a weinstein's bars didn't just extend
to him sexually abusing actresses,
but that his calm when harvey shot loads
on those branches,
that does branches like morphed because
of the.
The vile hatred for the female organism
was in his dna and those,
those trees like found human babies and
female babies and smothered him to
death.
yeah,
just started.
Harvey's come.
It's start producing movies.
It's like produced by a is harvey is
what it was like.
His ges contacted the bark of the tree
and created the new plague.
Whoa.
It's totally legit.
Possible.
Who the fuck knows what causes the
plague?
I was reading something about the black
death is spreading because people like
Arizona or some shit,
right?
No,
no.
It was somewhere in some place I'm never
going to visit,
and it was.
They were talking indie or some shit.
They were talking about how there's a
problem with a culture where people pull
the bodies out of the ground,
the zoom,
the bodies,
and we're dancing around them and it was
literally causing the black death
display.
Dancing with death.
Madagascar.
Plague is spreading because relatives
are digging up their black death corpses
and dancing as part of an ancient fama
de haan a ritual.
I mean that's commitment to dance.
That's commitment to stupidity.
where if someone's like,
oh,
you're gonna die if you do that.
It's like,
no,
I fucking loved dancing.
Did
the website from the sun.
Oh,
it's not real because this unreal or the
males not real.
One of them was not really both.
I think they both have questionable.
They're not the onion,
right?
They're not done,
so they're not.
They're not honorable.
more.
I think like that.
The fake old fake news thing from the
grocery store that you'd always see,
oh wait,
that kind of thing.
Almost like newsy is almost like legit
news at this point.
What is fake news and what is real news
anymore?
I have no idea.
It's almost like the opium wars where
it's like we're just flooded with
fucking info at this point,
which said jeremy.
So that's what those hearings are about
to.
I was just reading.
There's something tim cook gave a talk
this afternoon.
The apple guy?
Yeah,
based off of the.
He said is that the fake news spreading
is probably the bigger problem than the
russian ads.
He says the ads is probably like a point
one percent of the actual problem and
the ability for fake news to spread,
manipulate people through social media
is problems one through 10 and you can
be fixed.
It's a judge that that was almost like a
martin luther catholic church thing.
It's like,
oh no,
no,
no.
It's not.
Who gets to judge.
It's whether or not it's fake.
Like concentrating on who the person is
that gets the judge.
That's not helping anybody,
but what?
What's fake and what's not fake?
There's gotta be a way to differentiate.
This should be like a pregnancy test
for stories plus or minus and you're
like,
oh mine.
It says that for a second.
Before you tell me this story.
I want you to lick this piece of paper
is mother fucker.
That's hilarious.
What does it say where there is
cook?
Apple ceo says that,
scroll up.
There's a greater issue than russian.
Facebook didn't have that big hearing
going on today and yesterday.
Were there people from facebook,
twitter.
Why does everybody have to be number
one?
Why does it have to be the number one
problem?
Number one problem is Russia is not ads.
It's fake news.
Why is there a goddamn competition
between what sucks the most listened to
me,
tim cook,
they both suck.
The ads suck.
The stories that are fake,
stuck.
Everything sucks.
Stop making it about what?
Woo.
The number one problem is.
Not that it's trends.
Babies.
No,
no.
Yeah.
Like why kid?
Multiple things sucks.
Why don't we have a contest?
What is there a top 10 list of the
suckiest things about life.
how about things?
Just suck.
Yeah,
like me and my bro,
you know,
a fortune,
a comedian,
fortune.
Very funny.
Oh,
she's,
she's a,
she's a buddy of mine and we like,
we'll talk on twitter.
She's like,
who offer dissenting opinion,
but we're like buds.
So like we go back and forth and I was
like ripping on some fucking wine scene
type psycho.
And she was like,
yeah,
but what about the fact trump did this?
I'm like,
yeah,
both sucks.
Both suck.
Like the hold line in the sand.
Like you only can fucking say one thing
sucks is the end of our civilization.
And I think the one good thing,
the time.
Wait a minute.
What did I read?
I read a headline.
I didn't read the story,
but that weinstein said that this
happened to him to change humanity.
See if we could find that.
He might've been.
That's a fucking angle.
It's good angle.
If that's a great buddy.
And we were doing mushrooms together.
I was,
listen to me bro.
You just handle this right?
Good.
It's a good thing that you jerked on
that fight.
Not that part.
The fight.
The most forgivable part.
The part,
yeah,
that's uh,
he didn't say that.
Who said it?
It's a point of weinstein.
Pals said that his pals.
What?
Okay.
Weinstein tells pals.
Oh,
there you go.
Jamie.
Hey.
Well,
I mean this is secondhand information.
He wasn'T loaded.
he tells pals is a scandal happens so he
could change the world.
That's what I said.
So I'll make it larger.
It's the hero's journey for perverts.
It says disgraced.
Harvey weinstein has been telling what
friends he has left.
If there's a bigger reason that he's
embroiled in the ever wielding a
widening sexual harassment scandal to
change the world.
Sources tell page six.
I hate when they say sources say he's a
savior.
A hollywood insider says,
okay,
this is all bullshit.
Every swing,
but it's an interesting angle.
So let's keep going.
A source adds that.
The pervy wow.
That's rude.
Former weinstein.
Miramax,
miramax.
Matcher.
What's?
Some might have left out a word or the
letter word?
Miramax.
Marcher.
Mocker.
I don't know.
Oh,
like big mock.
Mock her.
Is that like a.
You never heard it used acidic word big.
I know there's like big maka,
but I don't think it's my her person who
gets things done.
Yeah,
it is big monster.
Nice yiddish.
There we go.
Has been telling a confidence that he
was born to take the fall for his
behavior in order to change the world.
He is resigned to his punishment as a
martyr for social change.
But here's the thing,
a comment.
A rep for weinstein commented.
That's absurd.
it is absurd.
But.
But here's the thing.
I think that's true.
I don't think that there's like some
crazy fucking destiny that he has the
golden ring and he was supposed to take
the fall,
but through his own folly,
through his own greedy fat chubby dick
trying to pump his ineffective lowe's
into the mouths of tens,
he really is going to change the world.
Yeah,
but he doesn't get to say it though,
like the other people have to feel it.
I don't know if he did.
It's,
it's,
it's one of these insiders that don't
exist.
They Might've been real,
but they might've been fake.
Jamie,
what do you do if you were a writer,
and I'm not saying this person did that,
you could have made that quote up and
just wrote an article,
but of course juicy headline that gets
talked about podcasts.
Sources could be like your horses.
I mean that was a.
I mean I hate to exonerate him,
but trump has said that many times about
some of the stores.
Is it the stories written about him?
They keep saying according to sources,
he's like,
you don't have any sources.
The sources do need to be protected for
journalists.
You're right,
so is a really weird sort of gray area.
You're right.
Yeah,
I mean there's.
There's only one way that someone's
going to give you information that could
possibly threatened their life if they
are.
There's no financial benefit.
No.
No societal benefit for them.
They have to be anonymous.
Right.
We've always been.
That was one of the main problems that I
had with the obama administration.
You know,
people sort of let them slide on that,
but it was one of the worst with whistle
ever.
There was a part of the hope and change
website,
a part of the hope and change website
that was later redacted or a deleted was
that they were talking about expanding
protection for whistleblowers who are
exposing someone breaking the law,
which is exactly what edward snowden
did.
Yeah.
That,
like obama trick me,
he tricked the trick me,
man.
I've already checked himself $2,
like this is going to unite the races of
America and he's going to be transparent
and he's such a good speaker.
He's made me cry like literally with
hope and then I see what the,
what he's,
what he does.
And I'm like,
dude,
you know,
seventy seven cents is bullshit man.
And it's like those little things where
I'm like,
what that is.
Oh the uh,
they say the wage gap between men and
women is seventy seven cents on the
dollar.
And he said that publicly,
publicly.
Right?
And it's one thing if it's buzzfeed,
it's the president of United States and
that is completely bullshit.
It's been debunked by the female
president of harvard.
Like this is not reality at all.
It's like.
And so when I see claim what it really
is though,
okay,
it really is more like a four cents.
Maybe it's uh,
uh,
they,
they don't include a factors such as
quitting for having a children or
dangerous jobs or all this shit that's
just a rough average.
But if you look at this man and a woman
with the same job for the same amount of
years with the same education,
it's basically the same.
It's very close
jobs.
A man makes more and they have
attributed that,
although there's no real way to tell,
but they,
uh,
they believed that's attributable to man
is more aggressive in negotiating his
initial salary total and subsequent
raises.
And,
and the,
the interesting thing is women are
better at negotiating for other people.
Like I've had female female agents that
are like,
vicious and awesome because they're
like,
it's almost like their baby cops where
they're like,
no,
they deserve more.
That's my baby.
But for themselves point.
Yeah,
for themselves.
They're not as alpha because I think
their attractiveness isn't bret
weinstein shit where it's like,
their attractiveness is.
So given that they don't have to,
like most men didn't fucking procreate
for most of human civilization,
so we're always just trying to be like,
look dude,
I got a car,
you know,
that's an interesting point because like
if you have a view like there's two
girls and one girl is like kind of gross
and overweight and the other girl is
really pretty.
The gross overweight girl will protect
that pretty girl,
like a fucking german shepherd.
Totally shielded,
but that the gross overweight girl will
fuck.
And then tire bus load of willing men of
course.
yeah.
Like men are like super excited about
her.
All the standards get out the window.
She has a couple of shots of vodka and
she's like fucking taking her bra off as
she's walking through those ills.
Expanding school bus doors for us
though,
tourists,
they call desert roses where it's like,
you know,
a is a 10,
but that doesn't happen the other way.
Like if,
if there's a bunch of women on a desert
island,
there's some fucking weinstein with no
movie credentials,
they don't read them.
They can just be like,
dude,
we can just hang out with each other and
just kind of cuddle and fuck anybody.
RighT.
But like dudes are like as low as it
goes,
we will potentially meet that standard
and that's.
And that's why it's like men can highly
spa,
get specific with their skillset,
but we're more susceptible to brain
damage.
But it's interesting.
We're talking about like a woman
protecting that other woman.
Oh,
100 percent.
Like I do a bit about how women are
socialist mentor capital.
That's where it's like women,
it's like,
oh,
she's having a bad night.
We all have to go home,
you know,
a linker tiers.
Ice cream man.
Or like he's been a buzzkill fucking cut
the week.
Yeah.
And the opposite is true.
We have to go home for debbie.
Yeah.
But the opposite is true.
Where it's like he's the fastest.
So it's like he's the funniest.
Let's make him king.
And women are like,
she has herpes tell everyone or.
No,
she's the,
she's the prettiest.
Everyone she has herpes.
It's the tallest nail gets hammered down
because in a galitary in societies like
the gatherers have to be like the same
and the hunters value skill,
so it's like,
can you shut your mouth and shoot a
fucking gun?
Great.
You're in versus like berry picking
there.
Like everyone's great.
Right?
Let's share.
Babies are shared berries.
I don't want to talk shit about debbie.
I just realized while drunk.
you're definitely drunk.
Yeah,
but the point I made is still valid.
The were good for awhile,
but he didn't know how to get off the
horse.
I said babies instead of berries.
That happens,
man.
You get to a certain point in your free
wall and you're like,
oh my god.
I'm like skiing down a hill that I.
I don't know how to stop it.
I just started winging it.
We've done enough.
This is three hours and 20 minutes,
right?
How many minutes?
Sweet.
Dude.
It's been a blast.
I love you man.
I love you too buddy.
Matt,
we did this.
He did.
I'm glad I was with you for the first
alcohol and the first marijuana hadn't
31 days and I'm here to tell you so
brighty as fucking highly underrated and
overrated at the same time.
It's overrated when it comes to
podcasts.
That's good.
Good.
Take a month off.
I like it.
It's respect.
Respect.
I feel good about it.
I'm excited.
I'm good to be back on the horse.
She take them on twitter to show her
fucking willpower.
No,
that's not worth it.
Well,
you have to promote gigs.
I think a month off interacting with
people.
It's not the worst idea in the world.
Just send some love out there and then
just walk away,
you know?
But do send some good positive feelings.
Don't worry about being sappy.
Why?
Why is sincerity sappy like what
happened?
Well,
are we so fucking cynical that someone
can say,
can't say much loved everybody.
Oh,
good pussy.
Sincerity became sappy somewhere along
the line.
Let's turn that around.
Turn it around.
Let's turn it around and all you bitches
out there that think that all white
cisgendered men are shit.
fuck that shit.
I pray for you to get some good dick.
Good,
good friends.
And so I'm happy
times to change your ways.
Same way.
Jamie kilstein did the same way.
I hope we all do.
God dammit.
All right.
We'll see you fucking freaks of the ice
house and a few hours,
but to keep this train rolling.
And then next week.
God damn young.
Jamie.
We've got a ton of fucking podcast next
week.
Oh kinds.
Oh shit.
Next week there's a paul stamets is
finally going to be here.
Chris kresser is going to be here again.
A bird r e n tom.
Nice.
On tuesday.
We're all gonna.
Get together and celebrate.
Sebastian younger is going to be here on
monday.
Oh jesus.
We might have marilyn manson called that
dude.
If you got his number.
Work this out mark and it makes it.
Yeah.
We'll try to get marquez.
How do you say his last name?
Alma brownlee.
Who's a my favorite tech expert.
Billy corgan from smashing pumpkins.
Jesus christ.
Fucking week.
Alright,
bye everybody.